[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. En direct. Nous vous
recevons dans le cadre de vos activités
de journalistes, de hackur, de tout un
tas de choses. Comment allez-vous ?
Antoine Champagne, présentez-vous
d'ailleurs.
Antoine Champagne, cfondateur du site
reflet.info, journaliste. Voilà.
Olivier Bluetooth, enfin comme lui.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la vie
Bluetooth ? Alors Olivier Laurellie a
aussi connu ce sous le nom de Bluetooth.
D'ailleurs, il y a eu peut-être un
abonnement Bluetooth qui n'est pas passé
d'ailleurs. Non,
un abonnement non, un abonnement. Ouais,
plutôt. Ouais.
Un abonnement Bluetooth. Non, ça j'ai
pas encore fait. Euh amendement, ça ils
ont essayé plusieurs fois, ça s'est pas
fait non plus pour plein de raisons,
j'en sais rien. Enfin voilà, mais enfin
pour l'instant, je suis plus condamné
qu'un amendement. Je suis plus un cas en
fait que
grand criminel. C'est ça.
Cyberterroriste
ayant failli buter toute la planète à
coup de clic.
C'est euh de clic dans Google quand
même. Attention, c'est
Est-ce que tu peux nous résumer ça un
petit peu trivialement ou euh
Oh là là, non, c'est pas trivial.
C'est étudié dans des faces et tout ça.
Donc non, c'est pas trivial en fait.
Bon, de manière très conne. Ce qui s'est
passé c'est que j'ai fait une recherche,
j'ai cliqué sur un lien, je suis tombé
sur des documents, j'ai téléchargé les
documents et j'ai été condamné non pas
pour intrusion mais pour maintien. Ça
veut dire qu'en fait, on m'a reproché de
m'être maintenu dans un espace public.
Mainti dans un système d'information
et maintien dans un espace public.
Maintien frauduleux dans un espace
public. Exactement.
Et et tu as été condamné ? Ououi,
j'étais condamné. Ouais.
Combien ?
3000 € d'amende inscripion casier
judiciaire.
Tu as payé ?
Ben ouais. Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ?
Enfin, tu es obligé de payer.
On reviendra, on reviendra sur ce
dossier un peu plus tard. Antoine
Champagne, cfondateur de Reflet.
Qu'est-ce que c'est Reflet ? reflet,
c'est euh en fait la rencontre entre
Olivier et moi, c'est euh une espèce de
complémentarité entre euh des
journalistes et euh et des gens qui ont
euh des capacités techniques euh voilà,
des
experts en sécurité informatique. Voilà,
l'idée était d'allier en fait nos nos
différentes méthodes d'investigation et
et de faire un journal pas comme les
autres en fait. Voilà, c'est né quoi
dans un café, on peut le dire hein.
Ouais. Voilà, on était en
combien de temps ? Il y a combien de
temps ?
Euh c'est c'est on est arrivé sur le web
en 2011. Euh en fait, on se lis
mutuellement nos différents sites et
cetera et puis on s'est rencontré à
passage en scène, on s'est revu, on a bu
un coup et en discutant de l'état de la
presse de voilà des journaux euh
que voilà qui répondaient plus tout à
fait à nos envies, en fait, on s'est
regardé puis on s'est dit "Bah, il y a
qu'en faire un journal et puis euh
voilà, on a fait reflet. Quel type de
sujet vous traitez ? Quel est le spectre
?
Bah le spectre est super large. En fait,
on a
obtenu un numéro de commission paritaire
dit IPG, donc presse généraliste, ce qui
laisse ouvert en fait tous les sujets.
On parle beaucoup,
je pense, de sujets sociétaux, de
d'économie. On a fait énormément de
choses pendant la la crise des subprimes
et ensuite la crise de des dettes
publiques. Euh et puis
nous on aime beaucoup.
Ouais. Et bah oui et
abonnez-vous reflet.info.
Ouais. Et donc euh voilà et puis on
parle aussi beaucoup de d'outils de
surveillance en fait liés euh à
l'explosion de d'Internet quoi. Olivier
euh Bluetooth,
ça t'est venu comme ça autour d'un café
euh de refaire ta presse, faire quelque
chose de différent, pas mainstream avec
tes tes tes outils ? Comment ça se passe
l'investigation chez pas venu en fait
tout seul ?
Concentre-toi s'il te plaît.
Ouais, ça m'est pas venu tout seul en
fait. Je je lisais Antoine depuis enfin
depuis j'ai 17 balis 16 balai quoi. Euh
faut comprendre qu'Antoine en fait c'est
un vieux dinosaure du net quoi. C'est
encore le c'est le seul mec qui a encore
un site web avec du comic en MS en fait
sur ses pages quoi. Et euh
et je le lisais en fait à l'époque
on s'est vu rencontrer une première fois
il y a très très longtemps à à la
nazolie un truc comme ça ou à la zoligue
conf
et puis ben on s'est retrouvé en fait un
petit peu par hasard en fait enfin c'est
à passage en scène fait comme comme il
le racontait. Et euh
le fait de monter un truc avec lui,
enfin c'était évident quoi. Enfin, c'est
c'est c'était logique en fait de faire
un truc avec lui quoi.
L'état de la presse entre un
journaliste, un hackur, qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ?
Alors moi je vois pas de truc de hacker
de de presse de machin et tout ça en
fait à l'époque où on est monté passage
en scène euh on voulait euh essayer de
se faire côtoyer certains milieux qui
étaient des milieux activistes un peu
hackur et tout ça et euh madame Michu
quoi. Enfin voilà c'est euh en gros bah
le hackur qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Enfin
pourquoi c'est pas un cybercriminel
forcément et tout ça. On a essayé de
redonner un petit peu les lettres de
noblesse au mot à cœur quoi. Euh faut
comprendre que le mot à cœur est euh
principalement associé à la notion de
cybercriminel en France.
C'est
que en France d'ailleurs
et que en France que en France mais
pourquoi ? parce que il y a eu les les
médias il ont énormément contribué. Il y
a enfin énormément de trucs aujourd'hui
quand on te parle par exemple de
Darknet, enfin voilà, c'est le
supermarché de la drogue où on achète
des USIS, enfin c'est un truc de ouf
quoi mais c'est enfin voilà enfin nous
on sait que c'est c'est pas ça en fait
c'est un maqui c'est un espèce de
liberté dans lequel des activistes en
fait de certains pays qui sont des
opposants politiques sur sous des
régimes dictoriaux et des trucs comme ça
mais enfin ils ont besoin de ce trucl
quoi. Euh
on a beau le savoir si tu veux, on a
beau essayé de l'expliquer, enfin c'est
un message qui ne passe pas quoi. Et on
a eu des exemples même avec reflet où on
a eu quelques
accroches avec certains médias où en
gros ils sont
quel
comment il s'appelle ? C'est direct 8,
c'est ça ? Euh C8, on a eu un moment et
qui qui avait repris en fait euh les
logs de reflets
pour euh illustrer euh les piratages
informatiques. Fishing non fishing un
sujet sur le fishing quoi. Donc voilà,
c'était en fait des logs de reflets qui
étaient passés dans une interview que tu
avais donné euh
et donc il m'avait gentiment flouté si
tu veux quoi mais sauf que tout le monde
m'a reconnu quoi. C'est même en me
floutant tout le monde m'a reconnu les
blog où il y avait marqué ou reflet. Quo
bon
et donc tout le monde m'a demandé si je
m'étais lancé dans le fishing quoi.
Ouais c'est super. OK, je me suis lancé
dans le fichier.
Bon, maintenant qu'on a fait votre
petite présentation, euh on va rentrer
un peu dans le dur. L'état de la presse,
on va commencer avec Antoine. Les fake
news, est-ce que la presse fait son taf
? Toi qui est journaliste, qui a monté
ton avec quelques potes, ton propre
programme de presse à ta sauce, est-ce
que tu as un regard critique sur tes
confrères ? J'ai pas un regard critique
sur mes confrères en particaliser
en fait. C'est un problème parce que
voilà, dès qu'on commence à critiquer la
presse
en étant soi-même
dedans, c'est compliqué. On peut pas
dire toute la presse
dysfonctionne, mais il y a quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes qui se
posent pour avoir été dans des
rédactions et pigistes. Il y a quand
même un certain nombre de problèmes qui
se posent. Le premier problème, c'est le
modèle économique. La presse classique
papier se meurt doucement. Les les le
nombre de de d'exemplaires diffusés d'un
grand quotidien national comme
Libération, c'est à pleurer en fait par
rapport au nombre de visites qu' peuvent
avoir sur leur site web. Donc il y a il
y a vraiment un déplacement du lectorat.
Leur modèle économique qui repose sur de
la pub et des investisseurs pose un
souci. Euh en tant que pigiste, on voit
bien euh vous avez reçu Fabrice Sarfi,
une histoire rigolote, des petits
camarades journalistes avaient proposé
un sujet sur un hôpital à Bengazi
financé par des Français. Enfin bon, un
truc un peu chelou euh au point et euh
et en fait, il s'est trouvé que ben
maquetter euh affiché sur le mur après
être après être imprimé euh le sujet a
sauté et la personne euh qui était mise
en cause dans cet article avait prévenu
les journalistes en disant "De toute
façon, votre sujet ne passera pas. Je
connais très bien une personne. Et
quelle est quelle est cette personne ?
Alors, je sais pas exactement. C'était
en fait un
investisseur ou un ami d'un d'un des
d'un des dirigeants du Point.
Effectivement, le sujet a sauté
proche des républicains.
Euh je sais pas, je sais pas, je peux
pas te dire parce que je connais pas le
détail de l'histoire mais bon après
cette histoire est ressortie ensuite sur
Media Part parce que Média part avait
dit que le point censurait des trucs et
le point s'était énervé et donc les
copains ont balancé l'histoire. Mais
voilà, on en arrive à des problématiques
comme ça en fait. les le le point
central en fait le la raison d'être de
de la presse, c'est d'informer un un
public quel qu'il soit, une presse de
droite, une presse de gauche, peu
importe, c'est d'informer un public sur
ce qui se passe dans le monde autour
autour d'eux. Si pour des raisons
d'amitié, de d'investisseur machin ou de
d'annonceur, c'est l'autre problème, le
problème de de l'argent. Si parce que tu
as quatre pages de pub SNCF, tu peux pas
faire un article qui critique la SNCF
dans dans le numéro en question, bah ça
pose un souci en fait. Ça veut dire que
bah la presse d'une manière ou d'une
autre, elle est plus libre en fait. Donc
voilà. Donc nous euh quand on a monté
reflets, on avait euh
comme comme truc central le fait de ne
pas avoir de pub dans les pages euh pour
ne pas être tributaire de de cette
problématique
un peu comme nous.
Un peu comme vous. et euh de ne pas
avoir d'investisseur extérieur parce que
voilà, on veut pouvoir faire notre
journal, nous journalistes euh voilà, ça
repose un peu sur le modèle non
reproductible du canard enchaîné euh qui
est exactement celui-là. En fait, les
journalistes sont actionnaires de leur
journal et et ils dirigent même leur
journal en se se ce coptant à des postes
de direction régulièrement. Ça tourne.
Voilà. Donc il y en a un qui s'occupe
des finances, l'autre qui s'occupe des
des procès, l'autre qui voilà. Donc euh
bon voilà, c'est un c'est un modèle qui
est pas reproductible complètement parce
que ils ont beaucoup d'argent. Mais euh
chez Reflet, vous avez euh sorti des
petits trucs quand même, non ? Amis, des
choses comme ça.
Ouais. Alors, on a eu du mal à faire
reconnaître le fait que c'était nous qui
l'avions sorti parce que voilà, on était
un peu un peu personne mais euh mais oui
oui, voilà l'histoire l'histoire de la
vente en fait d'un système d'écoute
globalisé enfin d'interception à
l'échelle d'un pays à à Kaddafi par la
France, enfin par une société française
mais très largement appuyée par l'État
français sous Sarkozy.
Oui, on a sorti cette histoire là et
puis après ça a été repris dans le Wall
Street Journal qui qui avait une
journaliste sur place à la libération de
entre guillemets de de Tripoli euh et
qui a visité par un hasard incroyable et
bon est tombé sur un des centres
d'écoute où il y avait des logos
amésesis partout, le numéro du mec
appelé à Paris si enfin à Boulogne s'il
y avait un problème et cetera. Donc ça
après ça a pris de l'ampleur. Mais ouais
mais
c'est vous qui était en en pointe de
diamant sur ce sujet-là. Ouais, on nous
a pris pour des tarer en fait.
Clairement
au début on nous a pris pour des tarer
et puis en fait
qui ont
tout le monde
la presse.
Bah tout le monde parce que en fait
c'est un peu la problématique habituelle
des
des gens qui voilà qui sont vite traités
de de de parano ou de
Ouais. Non mais un peu parano quoi.
Genre on nous surveille, on nous écoute
et cetera. En fait, tu as toujours des
gens pour dire "Non, c'est pas aussi
grave que ça et" et cetera. Voilà,
jusqu'au moment où il y a un Snowden qui
débarque avec des tonnes de documents et
qui montre que c'est vrai et c'est même
pire que ce qu'on pouvait imaginer.
Alors, c'est grave pendant 2 mois mais
après ça va mieux.
Voilà, après ça va mieux. Mais voilà,
Amésis c'est le même problème. Enfin,
après le on pourra en reparler mais
on va en reparler. On va on va donner la
parole à Olivier. Olivier, on en est on
en est où avec la surveillance en France
?
Alors, en France, c'est un peu compliqué
en fait à euh dresser un panoramaal de
surveillance en France pour plein de
raisons en fait. pe ?
Euh non, j'ai pas spécialement peur en
fait. Moi je suis déjà fiché enfin
jeffiché s tu sais j'ai failli tuer
toute la planète avec Google donc ça y
est c'est moi je sais que je suis dans
le cadran.
C'est la barbe qui fait ça peut-être.
Non
c'est écoute je la travaille enfin voilà
je fais ce que je peux. Euh non plus
sérieusement j'ai pas spécialement en
fait peur pour moi enfin mais par contre
j'ai peur pour un petit peu notre
démocratie en règle générale quoi. Enfin
c'est notre démocratie. Alors déjà, on
n'est pas en démocratie, on est en
République. Euh faut bien comprendre un
truc, c'est qu'on n'est pas spécialement
en fait le pays le plus attaché au
droits de l'homme, même si on a une
belle constitution et tout ça, en fait,
on fait des belles lois qui est en
principe en fait un truc qui fait une
ligne avec 45 articles derrière pour
donner des exceptions en fait au beau
principes quoi. Euh ça c'est le concept
en fait de la loi, comment elle est
faite en France.
Maintenant, enfin sur la surveillance en
elle-même, on a une problématique qui
est celle effectivement de la sécurité,
du terrorisme et tout ça, mais enfin, tu
vas raconter ça un irakin, il va être
mort derrière, quoi. Euh, on n'est pas
un état qui est spécialement
touché par le terrorisme, même si enfin,
on a vécu des trucs, on a vécu, on a
vécu des attaques terroristes et tout ça
qui sont déplorables et tout. Enfin,
voilà. Maintenant, est-ce que ça
nécessite vraiment le l'arsenat qu'on
est en train de déployer ? Enfin, je
parle de l'arsenal législatif, hein, je
parle pas de d'arsenal militaire et tout
ça, mais est-ce que l'arsenal législatif
en fait qu'on est en train de déployer
là-dessus et sa j'en suis pas convaincu
en fait. Enfin, j'en suis clairement pas
convaincu parce que enfin, je j'ai
l'impression en fait qu'on dépasse
systématiquement les objectifs et que en
fait cet objectif de d'avoir un arsenal
législatif qui va qui va permettre en
fait de surveiller de plus en plus de
monde et pas forcément des terroristes.
On voit ce que sont les fiches les
fiches S en fait aujourd'hui, c'est pas
forcément des gens qui sont reliés à des
histoires de djihad. Ça peut être
n'importe qu
des écologistes peut-être. Ça peut être
des écolos, c'est des des adistes, enfin
voilà, ça peut être à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi. À partir du moment où tu
touches aux intérêts économiques de la
nation, tu vois. Enfin, intérêts
économique de la nation, ça veut dire
quoi ? Quoi ? C'est euh
OK. Alors, moi, j'ai fait une recherche
dans Google, je je me suis retrouvé sur
un truc de la NS, donc j'ai atteint aux
intérêts économiques de la nation. OK,
donc je suis fichier S.
Euh, c'est un truc qui me qui me dérange
un petit peu en fait. Je parle pas pour
moi, enfin je parle en règle générale.
Enfin, c'est
donc là, il y a un réel souci déjà enfin
de
de de compréhension de ce qu'est le
enfin le une menace
contre le enfin enfin contre l'État, une
menace économique. OK, moi je veux bien
mais enfin c'est pas un truc qui va
toucher aux intérêts enfin suprême de la
nation quand tu as un zadiste en fait
qui va balancer quatre mails à ses
potes. Il y a un truc qui est pas
inintéressant à à relever, c'est que
à la suite des histoires Snowon aux
États-Unis, alors on sait on sait
maintenant quel est l'étendue en fait
des programmes variés en fait de la NSA
pour sur Wind et tout ça.
Oui. Alors il y a il y a plein de trucs
mais
ouais c'est pareil en fait on peut en
parler. Enfin c'est ça fait ça fait quoi
? Ça fait 15 ans en fait que tu étais
dessus toi.
Ouais. Je laisse la parole à Antoine.
Oui, mais
mais si tu veux, bon, tuas tu as des
programmes de surveillance de la NSA
dont don après, c'est la gestion
faire une petite digression, la gestion
par la presse des révélations Snowden,
c'est un problème pour moi parce que en
fait comme les documents sont distribués
par thématique, par pays à certains
journaux et cetera et que les
journalistes peuvent pas traiter tout ça
euh en même temps de manière coordonnée
et cetera, en gros, tu un article qui
sort à un endroit, un autre à un autre
avec un décalage de temps. Entre-temps,
on en parle plus et cetera. Donc c'est
de l'homéopathie journalistique.
Ouais. Voilà. Ça fait pas le bruit que
ça devrait faire. Ça l'a fait au début
et puis après en fait de temps en temps,
tu as un article qui sort, il y en a un
qui vient de sortir dans des intercept.
Bon OK. Mais donc tuas tu as quelques
sujets qui sont sortis, notamment un par
exemple qui était euh un programme de la
NSA qui visait à récolter tous les
toutes les photos euh circulant sur le
réseau avec un certain pourcentage de de
peau dénudé en fait. En gros, des
selfies à poil, quoi. En quoi ça aide à
lutter contre le terrorisme ? Je ne sais
pas. un autre programme euh viser à
prendre tous les euh
messages enfin toutes les informations
euh qui contenaient des infos médicales
avec une tendance psi. Pourquoi ? Euh
voilà, c'est pas expliqué. Mais alors ce
qui est intéressant de de dire c'est que
aux États-Unis
avec leur espèce de puritanisme si je
puis dire, en gros, c'est pas bien de
mentir. Donc quand tu vas devant le
congrès qui te qui te fait une petite
interview, tu es obligé de dire la
vérité. Bon et alors bizarrement, ils le
disent. Et donc en gros, il y a des
représentants américains qui ont fini
par poser la question aux gens du
renseignement leur en disant "Mais alors
vos programmes de la NSA révélés par
Snowden, ça a permis d'éviter combien
d'attentats ?" Et au début, tu as eu un
premier truc était une cinquantaine,
puis après c'est descendu à 10, puis
après à deux, puis à la fin, ils ont dit
zéro. En fait, on peut pas on peut pas
dire que il y a quelque chose qui est
permis de d'éviter des attentats. Donc,
est-ce que euh on est prêt à sacrifier
en fait la vie privée des gens ? Parce
que en vie privée, il y a marqué privée,
hein. Euh voilà, c'est c'est c'est un
des trucs qui est dans la Constitution,
je au tout début, euh voilà, on a droit
à notre vie privée. C'est un contrat
social le fait de vivre ensemble dans
une société, tu abandonnes un certain
nombre de trucs, mais en échange, on te
garantit d'autres choses. Bon, euh,
est-ce que on doit faire un trait sur la
vie privée des gens ? euh pour se
protéger éventuellement peut-être de
manière hypothétique, on sait pas trop
et cetera. Voilà. L'autre jour, il y
avait une conférence de monsieur Delon
qui est le euh la personne qui dirige la
la commission la CNCTR qui euh qui qui
s'occupe de superviser les écoutes en
France.
C'est commité audule en fait. C'est les
gens en fait qui sont obligés soi-disant
en fait de
Ouais. Il il vérifie que les demandes
des services de renseignement alors
parce que c'est les écoutes
administratives, on peut en parler aussi
les écoutes administratives, des écoutes
judiciaires. Bon, les écoutes
administratives, c'est à la demande
généralement d'un service de
renseignement et c'est autorisé par le
premier ministre. Euh, il y a pas de
juge qui supervise ce truc. C'est classé
secret défense et personne ne saura
jamais qu'il a été écouté euh ni
pourquoi et cetera. Et donc, il faisait
une conférence pour raconter son travail
et le fait que la commission
fonctionnait super bien et cetera. Et
donc je lui ai posé la question à la
fin, j'ai dit ben voilà, aux États-Unis
les représentants américains ont posé la
question au service de renseignement et
ils ont pas pu ils ont fini par dire
qu'en fait il y avait eu zéro attentat
des jouets euh sur la base de tous ces
programmes de de surveillance et en
France ce qu'il venait de dire qu'il
avait des contacts vraiment beaucoup de
contacts avec des services de
renseignement qu' avait des
allers-retours et cetera. Donc je me
suis dit bon bah probablement il doit
discuter un peu avec eux pour voir si ça
fonctionne ces trucs-là. Enfin voilà.
Et euh et en fait, il a beauté en
touche, il avait le droit de le faire
hein, mais il a beauté en touche en
disant euh moi je suis pas les services
de renseignement aller leur demander.
Donc on sait que les services de
renseignement répondent volontiers aux
questions des journalistes. On aura
jamais la réponse. Mais c'est
pathétique. En France, il y a pas de il
y a pas de de supervision de des
digne de ce nom.
Digne de ce nom ? Non. Oui. Oui.
Touffe.
C'est même pas une question de
supervision en fait à mon avis. C'est
vraiment une question de contrôle
démocratique, des écoutes. À partir du
moment où tu te retrouves euh ni sous
surveillance, donc on parle de tes
communications téléphoniques, de tes
communications électroniques, en fait,
un peu comme nous quoi.
Ben en gros, tout ta life en fait
euh quand tu te retrouves en fait sous
le coup de ce truc là, alors déjà le
premier truc c'est que tu peux pas y
échapper parce que de toute façon une
fois que tu es dans le target, bah tu es
dans le target hein. C'est pas là on
parle pas des coupes de masse, on parle
des coutes ultra ciblé. Euh les moyens
qui sont derrière sont euh enfin voilà,
tu peux pas lutter contre de toute façon
tu perds enfin voilà, tu vas te manger
du DD, tu vas te manger enfin tout ce
que enfin du 0D donc
on va on va t'infecter ta machine par
des vulnérabilités qui sont non voilà
par voilà par des vulnérabilités qui
sont pas connues de l'éditeur lui-même
donc il ne peut pas corriger lui-même.
Il y a un marché là-dessus quoi. Donc
les Italiens sont très forts avec ce
marché là. Non
bah les Italiens sont un peu moins
forts, hein, depuis que ils se sont fait
défoncer la gueule. Ils ont quand même
relancé leur activité. Les Français sont
très bons aussi. Là, on vient de se
lancer un private qui étaient les
Italiens. Donc
team,
team qui faisait quoi ?
Bah qui faisait des des ce qu'on peut
appeler des armes électroniques sur
mesure en fait pour les services de
renseignement qui permettent d'infecter
un téléphone ou un ordinateur et d'en
prendre le contrôle à distance.
Merci pour avoir délégué ce private
touf. Vas-y, continue.
Ben simplement pour terminer ce qui
s'est passé comme ça se passe à chaque
fois, ben enfin toutes leurs armes
électroniques se sont retrouvées en
accès public sur internet ainsi que leur
mail et tout ça. Enfin voilà, faut bien
comprendre un truc, c'est que à partir
du moment où tu es marchand d'armes où
tu vends ce genre de truc, où tu crées
ce genre de truc, il y a forcément un
moment où tu vas te manger l'effet boom
où elles vont te revenir dans la gueule.
Donc ça s'est passé avec toutes les
boîtes en fait qui font ça, strictement
toutes. Et ça s'est passé aussi avec des
des
ce qu'on appelle des super virus là, je
sais pas comment ils appellent ça en
fait. Stocknet
les STN et tout ça. Ouais voilà. Enfin,
je sais plus, je appelle ça Non, mais I
love you, c'est un truc mignon, ça
encore. Mais euh non, Stocksnet, enfin
par exemple alors pour resituer
Stockset, en fait tout le monde connaît
un petit peu le nom, mais en fait à
l'époque c'était euh c'était un projet
américain qui visait à euh
à ralentir voilà ralentir les
centrifugeuses en fait de la centrale de
Nathan en Iran
euh qui était censé fournir enfin enfin
fournir le programme d'énergie nucléaire
iranien quoi. Il avait pas une histoire
de serveur de jeu de foot ou un truc
comme ça dans la boucle ?
C'était alors serveur de jeu de foot,
non, enfin l'histoire en fait
l'opération s'appelait Olympic Games.
Donc voilà, c'est c'est l'opération
Olympic Games. Enfin, ça a été lancé
sous sous Bush. Euh Clinton a récupéré
le truc, enfin Obama a récupéré le truc
aussi derrière et il l'a continué. Donc
c'est un truc qui s'est déroulé en fait
sur plusieurs années. Euh il y a une
première phase en fait de d'infection de
de la centrale elle-même et puis de
mapping en fait de
pas de la centrale elle-même, c'est un
employé qui s'est fait véroler ensuite
non enfin il est rentré avec une clé
USB, il l'a branché et pouf enfin voilà
il
vo parce que parce que le le système
iranien était totalement hors ligne.
Ben [__] mais heureusement que les
centrales nucléaires sont hor liges
quoi. Je sais pas quoi te dire quoi.
Mais ouais, bon ok d'accord, elles sont
horling mais tu vois que ça suffit pas
quoi. Et donc la première variante en
fait de ce qu'on a connu en fait sous le
nom de Stock SNT est rentré sous forme
de nuclé USB dans une centrale nucléaire
iranienne. S'est retrouvé sur des
équipements de de contrôle et de
monitoring d'équipement industriel dans
ce qu'on appelle les scadar sur d'autres
centrales et puis après sur des Windows
et enfin et sur plein de trucs. Et on a
vu que l'infection en fait a enfin
explosé genre de truc quoi.
C'est c'est une arme en fait que tu que
tu déploies mais qui te retombe en fait
forcément sur la gueule à un moment. Les
risques pour nous c'est quoi ?
Alors euh quand tu t'attaques un
équipement industriel le risque en fait
il est tout con, il s'appelle la mort.
Alors, ça arrive à tout le monde, hein.
Enfin, c'est pas le problème. Mais euh
vous voyez, enfin le premier risque
effectivement, c'est la mort, quoi.
Enfin, en gros, quand tu fais péter une
centrale nucléaire, tu es à peu près sûr
que les gens qui sont autour vont
crever.
Euh après, il y a pas que ça. Enfin,
quand tu te retrouves par exemple, enfin
dans une grosse agglomération, je prends
par exemple le cas de d'une ville une on
va prendre une ville française.
On prend une ville française comme
Grenoble qui est dans une cuvette
avec des barrages au-dessus et tout
quoi. Et ben si tu t'amuses en fait à
lâcher le le barrage qui est a-udessus,
ben en fait, tu noisies Grenoble quoi et
tu fous un [__] de gros bordel quoi.
Mine de rien en fait, tu vas faire des
morts. Donc oui, le risque il est pas
anodin. Enfin, c'est à partir du moment
où tu enfin où tu vas t'attaquer à des
équipements industriels, que ça soit par
l'informatique ou que ça soit par des
bombes ou ce que tu veux, enfin c'est
pas le problème. Euh
un petit code de merde peut devenir une
bombe en fait, une bombe logique, un
truc comme ça et peut enfin voilà, il
peut avoir des conséquences mais euh
enfin oui, enfin sur
la France la France bosse sur ce type de
sujet ou pas du tout ? Alors, de plus en
plus, non, j'ai pas spécialement d'info
là-dessus parce que effectivement, c'est
pas des gens qui qui sont très causants
en fait quand tu leur parles. Ouais, ton
Scada, il est un petit peu déréglé, tu
es un peu à poil et tout, tiens,
regarde. Non, ça marche pas comme ça. En
fait, c'est des gens qui sont pas très
très rigolos déjà à la base donc ils te
causent pas. Euh, tu as beau le remonter
en fait que voilà, ils ont fait un petit
peu de la merde. Alors déjà, ils disent
même pas merci et puis enfin si tu
envoies pas les avocats déjà, tu as
clairement tu as de la chance.
Euh
mais enfin voilà, ça enfin c'est enfin
c'est connu quoi.
On avait quand même une société qui
était spécialisée dans ces sujets-là qui
s'appelait Vupen. Bon
qui est parti aux États-Unis
qui est parti qui s'est appelé autrement
qui a un autre business model maintenant
mais oui qui faisait des armes de ce
type là. Ouais.
On va on va demander à Antoine de
déployer le ce qui t'est arrivé
Bluetooth. Qu'est-ce qui était qu'est-ce
qui est arrivé à Bluetooth sur ses
attaques blanches ? Pas attaque blanche.
Qu'est-ce que Est-ce que les attaques
blanches en France sont respectées ?
Est-ce qu'on envoie tout de suite les
avocats au hacker quand ils découvrent
des choses ? Est-ce que c'est productif,
contreproductif ? Est-ce que ça ça
permet d'endurcir la sécurité française
ou pas du tout ?
Oh, on a la nuit là.
Ouais, ouais, vas-y.
Ouais. OK.
Un petit peu de gibin, tu veux ?
Ouais. Non, c'est c'est c'est
franchement un sujet compliqué.
Le le fait de
le fait de mettre en lumière, ça c'est
pas une question d'informatique ça,
c'est le fait de mettre en lumière
le les
défauts d'une personne.
Généralement cette personne ne prend
mal. Les gens ont un ego et voilà. Et
donc ils vont tout faire pour dire non
c'est pas moi et cetera. Donc en gros
quand tu arrives en matière informatique
et que tu dis à quelqu'un regarde là tu
as complètement merdé tout
fait tout régulièrement.
Ouais enf ce que ouais ce que moi je
faisais avant sur kitetoi.com mais de
dire voilà toutes tes données
personnelles que tu collectes en fait tu
les protèges pas elles sont accessibles
avec rien navigateur.
Voilà. Bon euh généralement les bah les
gens ils sont pas contents quand tu leur
dis ça. Alors même si tu les préviens
gentiment avant et cetera. Euh voilà.
Donc euh ouais, ce qui est arrivé à
Olivier, mais c'est assez marrant le
enfin pas marrant mais le le hasard de
de cette histoire, c'est que
effectivement
on s'est mis ensemble pour faire reflet
et on a eu exactement pour exactement
les mêmes raisons un procès. Euh
moi c'était donc il y a très très
longtemps, fin des années 90,
c'était la société Tati en fait qui me
faisait un procès pour pareil intrusion
et maintien frauduleux dans un système
de traitement automatisé de données. En
gros piratage informatique parce que il
comprenait pas que j'ai pu mettre en
lumière sur leur site les données
personnelles de leurs clients avec un
simple navigateur. pensait que forcément
j'avais piraté la base de données. Euh
donc il y a eu un procès et euh
autant donc
au moment où tu as un parquetier de
garde qui prend les dossiers qui dit
"Ouais, ça on poursuit, ça on poursuit
pas." Mon parquetier a dit "Oui, on
poursuit." Et entre ce moment et le
moment du procès, il y a quelqu'un au
parquet qui lui avait des connaissances
techniques vraiment poussées pour un
parquetier. C'est pas leur métier, hein.
Bon euh et qui a dit "Attendez là, il y
a un problème. Si on condamne cette
personne parce que avec un navigateur,
il est arrivé à un endroit où uniquement
dans la tête de l'administrateur c'est
un endroit privé mais il a pas dit que
c'était privé, donc il a pas mis les
droits nécessaires sur les fichiers pour
que ça demande un login, un password.
Donc ça s'affiche. Donc si c'est dans sa
tête que c'est privé et qu'on condamne
cette personne, en gros madame Michu,
elle va cliquer sur un lien Google. Elle
va arriver dans un endroit qui peut-être
dans la tête de l'administrateur est
privé et on va la poursuivre aussi.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les administrateurs
quand tu racontes que tu es arrivé dans
des documents machin internes, ils sont
pas contents. En tout cas, ils se font
tapés sur les doigts par leur direction.
Donc en gros, le parquet dit "Ah non,
non, non, finalement on poursuit pas. En
tout cas, on demande ça relaxe.
Euh, je suis quand même condamné en
première instance à je sais plus combien
c'était, mais un truc ridicule, 3000 €
3000 francs, 3000 € je sais plus 3000 €
mais avec surcis. Et donc là, je jette
l'éponge parce que ça faisait un an et
demi que je me prenais la tête avec ça.
C'était pas la même époque, j'avais
vraiment aucun soutien. Voilà. Donc
c'était financièrement lourd et
nerveusement un peu lourd aussi. Donc je
dis je jette les ponts, je fais pas
appel. Mais le parquet dit "Ah non non
non, nous on veut pas de cette
jurisprudence là, on fait appel à la
place de de la personne et euh on veut
obtenir ça relaxe." Et donc on repart
pour un tour en deuxème instance et là
effectivement je suis relaxé.
Et c'est marrant, enfin c'est marrant,
c'est bizarre les hasards. C'est
effectivement Olivier des années après,
une fois qu'on se met, c'est peut-être
mon karma qui voilà, mais des années
après on fait reflets, il tombe par
hasard dans un endroit où était stocké
des dizaines et des dizaines de
documents. Et
après, on peut expliquer pourquoi un
juge ne n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'il
y a pas de piratage, qu'il y a pas
d'intention délicueuse. Quand tu
télécharges tous les documents, c'est
pas parce que tu as cliqué sur tous les
documents les uns après les autres,
c'est parce que tu as lancé une commande
pour tout télécharger. Et puis
j'ai lancé une commande qui permettait
de télécharger tous les documents.
C'est c'est le fameux juge qui dit
Google.
Qui dit Google qui dit "Vous avez pas eu
peur de tuer toute la planète ?" parce
que vous étiez sur le site de l'ANSES
qui était en fait une espèce de truc de
protection sanitaire français et donc et
donc il est l'ANS pareil n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'elle a merdé dans les
droits qu'elle a donné à ces documents.
qui porte plainte et comme c'est un OIV
un organisme d'importance vitale et bien
c'est la DCRI ou la DG la DGSI déjà à
l'époque DGSI qui qui tombe sur le dos
de d'Olivier et tout le monde part envie
sur cette histoire et il se retrouve
devant un tribunal. il est relaxé en
première instance. Donc l'inverse de mon
truc est sans doute un peu sur la base
de la jurisprudence qui avait été la
mienne. Euh voilà. Mais le parquet,
complètement l'inverse pour que que pour
moi, le parquet fait appel de cette
décision
qui qui au parquet.
Alors bon, on a su après parce qu'on a
un petit peu enquêté quand même mais on
a su après que derrière tout ça, il y
avait Muriel Keméner qui est la personne
au sein du parquet français qui est
Myiam. J'ai dit Muriel. Myiam, pardon,
Myiam Keméner qui est euh un peu dite
spécialisée sur les histoires de
nouvelles technologie de sécurité
informatique.
Euh pour l'avoir entendu parler deux
trois fois dans des conférences, ses
connaissances informatiques sont proches
de zéro et de sécurité informatique. En
fait, elle ne connaît probablement que
ce qu'elle lit dans le JDN ou des trucs
comme ça. Donc, elle a ces espèces de
bah c'est c'est
comment dire ? C'est un business comme
un autre. Voilà, on se met sur un sur un
truc porteur, un créneau porteur. Voilà.
Bon, une nouvelle techno. Bon, il y a
pas grand monde dessus. Voilà. Et donc,
elle est une espèce de référence au sein
de la justice française sur ces
histoires là. Quand tuinterroges un
petit peu des
des gens dans le dans le milieu
judiciaire, tout le monde te dit "Oui,
effectivement, bon voilà, mais euh bah
voilà." Bon bah c'est c'est elle et bon
voilà c'est elle qui donne le ton et
donc en fait elle elle a vraiment voulu
la la condamnation d'Olivier. Elle
voulait une jurisprudence sur le vol de
données qui existait pas jusque-là.
Puisque quand tu voles une donnée en
fait tu la voles pas, tu tu la copies,
tu la soustrais pas à son personne qui
la détient. Donc bon, elle voulait une
jurisprudence là-dessus et voilà, elle a
demandé sa condamnation en appel et elle
a gagné. Donc on nous on s'est dit c'est
pas possible. Euh on est parti en
cassation et on a perdu. La cassation
c'est pas sur le fond, c'est sur le
droit, donc c'est plus compliqué. Euh on
a perdu et donc c'est une jurisprudence
maintenant qui est franchement grave
pour tout le monde parce que n'importe
qui peut être condamné parce que il est
arrivé dans un endroit voilà qui dans la
tête de l'administrateur
est privé alors que c'est marqué nulle
part en fait.
Olivier,
ça fait du bien un petit peu d'avoir des
des fans club au sein du parquet.
Ouais. Alors en fait si tu veux entre le
fan club de Levalois et le fan club du
parquet, enfin c'est le genre de fan
club dont je peux me passer en fait
c'est la DCI, la DGSI.
Oui. Ouais. Alors parce que
les bruyères
alors ouais faut faut faut bien
comprendre que alors on parlait de la
première affaire, j'ai eu une seconde
affaire et tout ça. Euh j'ai eu accès au
dossier d'instruction, j'ai
à peu près l'habitude de ce que peut
être en fait une enquête normalement
judiciaire donc à charge et à décharges
et tout ça.
Et je pense que je publierai un jour ou
l'autre en fait une enfin voilà, je
pense je pense que je publierai le truc
carrément parce que en fait c'est
tellement comique
que enfin c'est c'est ça vaut le coup de
comprendre en fait comment fonctionne au
enfin un moment.
C'est un acharnement contre toi ? Non
non, je je parle pas d'acharnement.
Enfin contre surtout pas contre moi.
Enfin, je suis insignifiant en fait.
J'ai pas je vois pas pourquoi on
s'acharnerait contre moi.
Par contre, je veux bien croire que un
moment ou un autre ça
permettre en fait à certaines personnes
euh
de briller en société.
Exactement. Enfin voilà. De briller dans
le dans je ne sais quel cercle de la
cybersécurité pour pas le nommer. Euh
c'est notre procureur Poupar.
Je sais pas, enfin je je m'en fous en
fait si tu veux parce que faut faut bien
comprendre un truc en fait. Quand tu te
retrouves au tribunal avec un procureur
qui va te défoncer la gueule parce que
c'est son métier euh
son métier c'est pas ça.
Si c'est son métier là pour le coup
enfin c'est quandme son méti quand même
le procureur qui demande qui demande la
condamnation. Dans mon cas c'était très
particulier mais normalement c'est le
procureur qui demande la condamation.
C'est intéressant de noter que en appel,
parce que moi j'étais à son procès, euh
la proc a commencé euh ses ses
réquisitions en disant euh j'imagine que
personne ici euh n'a compris un/ers de
ce qui s'est dit comme moi mes enfants
auraient mieux compris mais je vous
demande de condamner monsieur Laurélie.
Ça donne une franchement une mauvaise
image de de la justice parce que si tu
comprends pas ce qui se passe, bah faut
prendre le temps d'essayer de comprendre
parce que tu peux pas condamner
quelqu'un sur un truc que tu as pas
compris. Enfin voilà quand le quand le
juge en première instance c'est en
première instance où il disait le login
pour login non c'est en app
c'est en appel le login pour le login
Google pour Google enfin on voit que ils
sont complètement paumés quoi. Ils
savent pas de quoi on parle donc
essayent de justifier leur salaire
justifier leur place. Non non mais non
mais ils sont dans leur rôle mais c'est
vrai que on aurait pu espérer que s'ils
ne comprennent pas ce dont il ce dont on
parle il fasse appel à des experts. Il y
en a plein qui viennent
bah il y en a plein. Il a Zitom enfin
voilà
des experts judiciaires sur des
questions en fait cyber il y en a c'est
pas le problème.
Il y en a des bons. Donc on peut on peut
s'allier voilà les experts pour essayer
de comprendre exactement ce qui s'est
passé. Une question d'internet qui vient
de nous tomber. Existe-t-il aujourd'hui
un organisme visant à surveiller les
activités des entreprises Haïti Cybersec
installé en France afin d'assurer que
leurs activités ressent restent
compatibles avec les droits de l'homme ?
Non.
Avec les droits de l'homme ? Non. Alors
clairement, enfin les droits de l'homme
en fait si tu veux en fait il y a deux
trucs. Il y a le pognon et il y a les
droits de l'homme. En principe les deux
sont tout le temps en fait 1000 mis l'un
à côté de l'autre et c'est rarement les
droits de l'homme qui gagnent. On va
savoir pourquoi. Euh mais euh Non non
non clairement pas. En fait, au au
niveau de la sécurité, enfin voilà, au
niveau de la sécurité des des
entreprises, que ça soit des enfin sur
les PME, tu as euh comment ça s'appelle
le tu as le clusif qui fait énormément
de enfin voilà, énormément de boulot et
tout ça, de sensibilisation, de
d'évangélisation, on va dire. Après, sur
les OIV, ben c'est le vel au-dessus
hein, c'est DGSI et ANC. Euh LCY vise de
plus en plus à démocratiser un petit peu
son discours sécurité des systèmes
d'information. Le LANC essaie de plus en
plus de de démocratiser un petit peu son
discours et de l'offrir un plus grand
nombre et c'est vachement bien ce qu'ils
font.
C'est mieux depuis que il y a plus
Poupard. Non,
c'est enfin Poupar a balancé une
impulsion qui était ultra intéressante,
mais vraiment ultra intéressante en fait
c'est je pense que ça a été le premier
qui a ouvert
un dialogue avec les gens de l'extérieur
quoi, tu vois. Enfin, c'est
avant Pouard, c'était qui ? Ah,
je sais même plus. Enfin, j'en sais rien
du tout quoi. Enfin, c'est Je suis pas
dans le secret des dieux là-dessus,
quoi. Euh Poupar était le premier à
communiquer en tout cas et il l'a bien
fait.
Il a super bien fait quoi. Donc enfin
je sais pas ce que ça va devenir.
Sympa sympa sans t-shirt à la nu qui
venait. Ah ben écoute, je sais pas, on
s'est pas tapé dans le dos hein. Mais
enfin
moi ce que j'ai vu de Lency quand il
quand il était quand il était aux
affaires, bah c'était plutôt pas mal
quoi. Enfin c'est ça a été les premiers
signes d'ouverture en fait sur son monde
extérieur quoi. Enfin c'est et puis
décifier un petit peu tout ce qui se
passait au niveau au niveau cyber quoi.
Ce qui se passe avec la surveillance en
tout cas en en France. Après bon pour
les autres pays, je je peux pas parler
mais c'est que la surveillance vise à
surveiller. Mais qui surveille la
surveillance quoi, en gros ?
Bah ouais voilà, c'est un peu c'est un
peu le problème, c'est effectivement en
France
bah la supervision euh démocratique de
la chose, voilà, le rôle du parlement
là-dedans est très faible. Voilà, c'est
c'est
Tu as une petite histoire à nous
raconter là-dessus d'ailleurs. Sous
l'air SarkoZi, est-ce que on a mis de la
boîte noire ?
Ouais. Alors, c'était les boîtes noires
avant les boîtes noires. C'est
franchement notre plus beau fiasco de de
proposer en fait les boîtes roses, ils
en ont pas voulu en fait c'est parce que
c'était moins anxiogène mais enfin
voilà. C'est c'est le scoop qui a fait
le plus gros flop de reflets. On avait
sorti cette enquête en fait en
collaboration avec Media Part. on avait
bossé ensemble sur le sujet et on a
sorti deux articles en même temps et ça
s'appelait IOL. En fait, ça partait d'un
document sur lequel on était assis
pendant des mois, essayer de de
comprendre ce qu'il y avait derrière et
finalement on a on a enfin trouvé les
gens qui qui voulaient bien en parler.
Euh je essayer de schématiser pour que
tout le monde comprenne. En gros, si tu
veux surveiller tout l'internet français
euh tu peux pas te mettre
euh au cœur du du réseau parce qu'en
fait
en fait il y a pas de centre d'internet
en
voilà il y a pas de centre d'internet,
il y a beaucoup d'acteurs.
Voilà, il y a beaucoup d'acteurs
heureusement mais enfin ça n'empêche pas
queon peut faire quand même des trucs
quoi. Alors que euh par exemple en Libye
pour le truc pareil sous Sarkozy, donc
la vente d'un système qui permettait de
d'écouter tout l'internet libien, bah tu
avais un fournisseur d'accès qui était
le point d'entrée, tout passait par là.
Bon en France, c'est pas pareil. Donc en
gros, ils ont eu une idée un peu euh
géniale qui était de se dire ben ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va se mettre
au point de raccordement où chaque
abonné est raccordé au réseau. En gros,
ce qu'on appelle les deslam. Alors bon
voilà, c'est des NRA plutôt
les n de raccordement abonnés. Donc
c'est des euh
c'est des bâtiments dans lesquels tu as
des installations qui permettent à euh à
des opérateurs de connecter une ligne
téléphonique sur de la DSL.
En gros, quand tu changes de quand tu
changes de de fournisseur d'accès à
internet, on te dit bah oui, ce serait
sera opérationnel dans une semaine, le
temps qu'il y ait un mec qui aille dans
le NRA et qui prenne la fiche de ton
numéro de téléphone et qu'il la change
pour la mettre de Orange chez Free ou de
Free chez SFR, enfin ce que tu veux.
Donc voilà. Et donc ils sont ils sont
dit, on va se mettre là-dedans et on va
mettre des boîtes noires là-dedans.
Alors les boîtes noires en gros,
cit légal.
Ouais. Non. Alors non, justement en gros
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont mis
ce qu'on appelle des sons DPI euh
Deep Packet inspection. Deep Packet
Inspections, en gros, ça euh inspecte
tous les petits paquets informatiques
qui passent sur le réseau et euh
en profondeur
en profondeur et ça les stock dans une
base de données et après tu as des une
interface pour aller euh voilà, tu vas
rentrer l'email d'une personne et puis
sachant qu'an en fait ne stockait pas
tout par défaut
mais
s'offrait la capacité en fait
d'intercepter la connexion de n'importe
quel abonné internet euh sur une
connexion domestique ou professionnelle.
Voilà. Alors, ce qui est euh rigolo,
c'est que dans le dans le document qui
qui a servi de de base à notre enquête,
on se rend compte que on parle de cible
en fait. Alors, une cible, ça peut être
une personne comme ça peut être euh euh
un réseau un peu plus grand, quoi. Et en
et en gros,
une des fonctionnalités euh qui était
euh listée euh dans le dans le document
technique, c'est que tu pouvais mettre
sur écoute en fait euh
géographique.
Ouais. En fait, une une un certain type
de classe d'adresse IP. On va pas
rentrer dans le détail mais en gros si
tu veux sur un réseau d'entreprise tu as
généralement 254 machines qui sont sur
une plage d'adresse IP. Donc si tu tapes
cette plage bah tu vas taper les 254
machines. Là c'est une classe supérieure
et donc c'est 64000 et quelques. Je sais
plus jamais le le nombre mais en gros tu
pouvais te prendre 64000
adresse IP et les mettre sur enfin les
intercepter leur trafic. En gros, c'est
c'est tu mets pas une fonctionnalité
comme ça si c'est pas pour s'en servir
quoi. Enfin ou alors c'est complètement
débile. Mais
voilà. Donc c'est c'était effectivement
sur le papier, c'était assez inquiétant
comme truc et effectivement à l'époque
c'était totalement illégal.
Non à légal.
Merci à légal.
Il y a un jargon à utiliser dans la
langue française pour les dit. Je pense
que n'importe quel étudiant en droit de
première année, c'est que en gros, il y
a les choses qui sont légales et les
choses qui sont illégales mais que au
milieu il y a pas. Donc voilà, c'est
dans la loi ou c'est pas dans la loi
pour notre démocratie
ça fait flipper. Non.
Alors déjà parl Oui, ça dépend public,
ça dépend de la volonté politique qu' a
derrière en fait.
C'est tout le problème. Il faut pas
enfin on peut pas dire voilà les
services de renseignement c'est pas beau
et cetera. En gros, tous les pays,
toutes les démocraties, toutes les
Républiques, tout ce que tu veux, tout
le monde crée un service de
renseignement. Mais pourquoi ? Parce que
d'un côté, tu as la police qui pourrait
te servir pour voilà surveiller les gens
ou éviter qu'il y ait des crimes, des
délits et cetera. Mais pourquoi tu crées
un service de renseignement ? Parce que
tu vas leur faire des choses que la
police ne peut pas faire. En gros, dans
un service de renseignement, la limite,
c'est ne pas se faire prendre. Tu vois,
tu évites par exemple quand tu fais
sauter un bateau en Nouvelle-Zélande de
Greenpeace,
Rainbow Warrior,
Rainbow Warrior, tu évites de te faire
prendre, sinon c'est pas bien. Voilà.
Mais en gros, tu fais à peu près ce que
tu veux.
Euh le problème, c'est que ces services
là sont justement au service des
politiques qui sont au pouvoir. Donc
tout dépend du politique qui dirige ton
pays. Est-ce que il veut aller plus
loin, pas plus loin ? Est-ce que c'est
donné des lames de Est-ce que c'est
donné des lames de rasoir à des singes ?
Euh ouais, peut-être. Oui, oui. Bah oui.
Oui. Bah le problème après enfin tu as
plein de trucs qui rentrent en compte.
suite à le fait que entre ce que va te
vendre une entreprise, là en
l'occurrence, nous on s'était basé sur
une proposition de d'une boîte qui
s'appelle Cosmos
euh pour un opérateur, un des quatre
grands opérateurs et tous les opérateurs
devaient installer ce type de matériel,
ils pouvaient choisir leur fournisseurs.
Voilà, chacun faisait appel à son
prestataire. Il se trouve qu'on est
retombé encore une fois sur Cosmos
plus grand des hasards.
Cosmos qui est
bah qui fabrique un vieux copain
Ouais. qui fabrique des sondes des pays
en fait et qui les vend un peu voilà
sans faire trop attention puisque ils
avaient essayé de le vendre au sein d'un
consortium international, ils avaient
essayé de le vendre à la Syrie de Bachar
Elassad donc voilà bon après le
l'affaire a capoté mais retiré pour des
questions éthiques 3 ans après qu'on
leur posé la question si on allait pas
les retrouver en Syrie ou en Libye et
tout ça quoi.
Donc en gros
en gros 3 ans après pour des raisons
éthiques, tu comprends ils sont retirés
parce que mais c'était compliqué. Vous
avez un un dialogue avec Mounier Majobi
ou pas du tout ?
Un dialogue avec Mounier Majubi ? Euh
alors moi j'apprécie la personne enfin
clairement.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je l'ai rencontré plusieurs
fois et avant qu'il soit en poste enfin
et j'apprécie réellement les personnes.
Maintenant de l'avoir un dialogue par
rapport à des questions de surveillance
de machin. Non pas du tout. Non non
vraiment pas non.
Ce serait nécessaire ou pas ? Mais enfin
non mais de toute façon il a pas son mot
à dire.
Voilà
c'est enfin il a clairement pas son mot
à dire. Mais il faut bien comprendre un
truc en fait si tu veux en fait dès que
tu parles d'internet
je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Il y a dès que tu causes internet en
fait tu t'adresses pas au ministère du
numérique machin. Déjà c'est pas un
ministère c'est un secrétariat d'État
qui dépend de Ber quoi. Donc en fait on
parle du ministère du pognon des
internets. Donc si tu veux en fait
internet c'est un marché à conquérir
comme l'avait expliqué SarkoZi et une
terre aborigienne à civiliser. Voilà.
Attention toutes les cultures ne se
valent pas.
Exactement. Bon,
partant de là, tu te doutes bien que
enfin c'est pas les droits de l'homme,
c'est pas la liberté d'expression, c'est
pas tout ça qui va gagner quoi. C'est
c'est Bercy qui est aux manettes quoi.
Enfin si c'est Bercy qui est aux
manettes, c'est parce qu'il y a des
taxes à prendre et à chaque problème sa
taxe quoi, tu vois. Enfin chaque
problème tu bercou dans où on est dans
un climat de guerre économique. Le
secret des affaires, ça fait ça vous
fait penser à quoi ? Tu as pas attendu
internet pour être en guerre économique,
quoi.
Le secret des affaires.
Euh, je te laisser parler parce que je
vais te grossier.
Ouais. Bah, le secret des affaires, bah
c'est un bon moyen de faire terire les
journalistes d'investigation.
Euh, c'est le bon moyen de pouvoir
continuer à faire des affaires en rond
comme on veut. Et euh il se trouve que
effectivement bah les gens pointent dans
la lutte contre ce projet de loi.
Lesquel ? Euh bah tu t'as Élise Lu euh
qui qui gueule
qui gueule partout mais euh voilà, c'est
des gens qui creusent, qui font de
l'investigation et euh qui euh
généralement euh euh par leurs enquêtes
ternissent un petit peu l'image dorée
que veulent se faire les entreprises.
Les entreprises le le enfin là encore
une entreprise sa raison d'être la
plupart du temps c'est de faire du
pognon. Bon euh les questions éthiques
et morales
passent généralement après. Tu peux
avoir des patrons qui ont une certaine
éthique ou une certaine morale et qui
essayent de l'appliquer dans leur
business. Ça peut exister. Juste enfin
sur ce que tu viens de dire. Enfin il y
a un truc qui est qui est assez
symptomatique en fait de ce que tu viens
de dire.
Quand on a commencé à bosser sur
l'histoire d'Amésis, on s'est retrouvé
assez rapidement avec Paul Morera que tu
as reçu d'ailleurs ici.
Salut Paul.
Ouais. et euh qui a euh qui qui avait
fait un enfin un super reportage qui
s'appelle Traqué d'ailleurs et euh où il
expliquait où il avait interviewer un
mec euh d'Amésis, enfin qui bossait pour
Amesis à l'époque où ils ont vendu un
système de surveillance à Kadfiille
quoi.
Et le mec te dit texto, il te fait la
morale, on l'avait mise de côté.
Attends sur l'histoire d'Amésis quand
même pour que les gens comprennent bien
le le l'histoire quoi. Est-ce qu' y a il
y a il y a il y a l'histoire qu'on a
raconter ? Il y a le fait queon est
vendu ce truc là et que et enfin
aujourd'hui il y a une une procédure en
cours tribunal de Paris pour complicité
de torture. Euh
crime contre l'humanité non ?
Ouais c'est c'est le pôle crime contre
l'humanité mais c'est le le truc qui le
reproche c'est une complicité de
torture. Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a des
des gens qui ont été torturés sur la
base de ces interceptions. Euh il y a
quand même un truc qu'il faut que les
gens comprennent, c'est que
à l'époque sous Sarco,
le gouvernement français pousse une
petite SS2 française
en essayant de vendre à Sarco entre
autres choses puisqu'il y avait aussi
des centrales nuclé une centrale
nucléaire, il y avait des rafales,
c'est un contrat globalement security.
Ouais. Voilà. Euh oui, pardon à Kaddafi,
mais c'était Sarkozi qui était à la
manœuvre.
On essaie de vendre à Kaddafi une
centrale nucléaire. Déjà l'idée bon
euh des rafales machin et un système qui
permet de mettre sur écoute 20. Qui est
la personne qui est l'interface
de cette entreprise au niveau enfin
commercial quoi. L'interface au niveau
liben
qui va prendre des mallettes de billets.
Non, même pas même pas. C'est pas le
problème. Chef de projet lib. Qui est le
chef de projet libien pour cette
histoire ? Abdallah El Senusi. Abdallah
Elenusi, il est condamné en France déjà
à l'époque
pour terrorisme
par contumas pour terrorisme
pour l'affaire du
pour l'affaire du décéd du TH qui avait
sauté qui avait été
170 morts pas pas tous français mais 170
morts.
Le gars il est condamné pour terrorisme.
Bon, après on on raconte cette histoire
et qu'il y a une journaliste qui va
interroger quelqu'un chez chez Amésis,
les gars, il dit "Oui, mais on vendait
un truc pour lutter contre le
terrorisme." Les gars, quel processus
mental vous amène à vendre un système
pour lutter contre le terrorisme à
quelqu'un qui a été condamné en France
comme terroriste ? Enfin, voilà quoi, la
morale, voilà. Bon oui, c'est c'est une
question dessous, mais la morale,
l'éthique, tout ça, c'est c'est
complètement en dehors du du champ de
vision de ces gens-là.
Tu veux rebondir Olivier ?
Rebondir là-dessus, c'est un petit peu
lourd mais euh
non, enfin c'est c'est clairement lourd.
Enfin, l'histoire de d'Abdal aussi. Oui,
effectivement, on a on a bien creusé le
truc. Euh il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui,
on se demande si Sarkozy a bien touché
ses 50 patates et tout ça. Enfin, voilà.
Euh derrière le financement en fait d'un
parti politique, il y a des trucs qui
sont vachement plus sales derrière quoi.
Et euh alors si en fait cette histoire
sort par le biais en fait du financement
de la campagne de Sarkozi, ben c'est
très très bien. Euh maintenant en fait
il y a il y a il y a clairement plus ça
derrière et euh ben il y a plus ça en
fait dans le sens où comme disait
Antoine à partir du moment où tu vends
un terroriste
un système soit-disant pour traquer du
terroriste et du pédophile. Excuse-moi
mais le pédophile libien, enfin fallait
le chercher à cette époque quoi, tu
vois.
Euh il y en a forcément, c'est pas le
problème mais en fait quand tu fais un
système d'interception à l'échelle d'une
nation, c'est pas pour traquer du
pédophile. Pédophile tu
est-ce que tu penses qu'il y a un
système d'interception à l'échelle d'une
nation en France ?
Alors logiquement, légalement, on n' pas
le droit.
Euh
oui, enfin toutes les lois en fait qui
ont été passées viennent à chaque fois
légaliser des choses légaliser un truc
qui était déjà en place. On vient de te
parler d'IOL. On vient de te parler
d'IOL. IOL c'est un système
d'interception
interception obligatoire légale. Et ça
c'est quelque chose qui à l'époque quand
ça a été mis en place n'était pas légal
et qui a été légalisé. Ça commencé en
2006. Ils l'ont ils l'ont égalisé en
je crois.
mais ils l'ont légalisé bien après quoi.
Donc voilà, la loi
sur le renseignement 2015 pareil, ça
rend légal des choses qui n'étaient pas.
Bon voilà, c'est à chaque fois. On a des
gros jeou, on a des super jejoux. Enfin
voilà. Bon, c'est pas trop légal mais
c'est pas grave, t'inquiète pas. On va
faire une loi pour alors attends, ça va
être un petit peu voyant. Alors,
attends, on va pas faire une loi, on va
on va essayer d'amender une loi puis de
faire une autre loi derrière et puis on
va essayer de faire passer une directive
européenne comme ça.
Plus c'est gros.
Ben ouais, enfin mais c'est c'est des
assemblages en fait. Mais
ça pose aussi plein de questions
sociologiques. C'est-à-dire que en gros
si tu veux les gens
sont trop cons pour comprendre.
Mais non mais mais non mais ils
acceptent.
On force le trait parce que on nous a un
peu chambré sur cette question là.
peu chambré sur cette questionlà.
Ils sont pas équipés pour comprendre.
Bah tu as tu as plein de gens qui bon
jusqu'à je pense que jusqu'à Snowden et
très bizarrement jusqu'au récent
scandale Facebook
Cambridge Analytica, les les gens
comprenaient pas de quoi il s'agissait
quoi. Euh nous on gueule dans le vide
depuis quoi 20 ans en disant
combien combien tu as d'abonnés
de quoi chez reflet on est à presque 600
combien ça coûte reflet par mois
à faire à payer si je veux m'abonner
chez
to0 de café quoi.
Pour avoir des informations de cette
qualité là
ouais
tu es un moine bénédictin toi non ?
Ouais un peu. Ouais
un peu.
Ouais ça fait longtemps que c'est
Abonnez-vous à Reflet.
Ouais. Euh une question, on on on va on
va switcher un petit peu pour revenir
sur ces questions là après. Vous avez
pensé quoi de cette affaire des trolls
russes que d'ailleurs notre ami Paul
Morera a mis en lumière avec sa petite
visite à Saint-Pétersbourg et de son
usine à troll ? Mais
ça vous a ça vous a fait penser à quoi
cette histoire d'astroturfing ? Pas
l'astroturfing ?
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est
l'astroturfing
? Non, mais ça fait penser à rien parce
que en fait tout ça c'est des non
questions. En gros, si tu veux les
guerres psychologiques et les guerres de
de
voilà de de gens qui ont des des des
agendas politiques, des États qui ont
des agendas politiques, enfin tout ça
c'est pas né avec internet. Internet
c'est une photocopieuse. Ça photocopie
le monde réel mais ça le rend numérique.
Évidemment, c'est plus puissant, c'est
plus rapide, ça accélère tout ce que tu
veux mais tous ces trucs là existaient
déjà avant. Les guerres d'influence, les
espions, enfin voilà, John Lecré,
Vetrop,
bah tu on on voilà, on a rien de de neuf
en fait. C'est juste que effectivement
l'effet est un peu plus visible, plus
puissant, ce que tu veux.
Tout le monde le fait en fait.
Mais tout le monde le fait. Tout le
monde le fait.
Touf. Il trouve que les Russes en fait
se sont fait prendre. OK. Euh
maintenant, je suis pas sûr que la
France ne se fasse pas prendre dans les
5 ans à venir. Je suis pas sûr que les
États-Unis se fassent pas prendre dans
les 6 mois à venir.
L'Arabie Saoudite, Israël,
pareil. Enfin, c'est Oui, effectivement,
enfin, à partir du moment où tu as un
médien en fait qui est euh
aussi puissant qu' internet qui est
aussi rapide, qui est aussi
facile à manipuler avec peu de monde en
fait. Qui touche de gens,
voilà. et qui touche qui qui touche
plein de monde. Enfin, tu toi tu es seul
en fait dans ta chambre, tu peux parler
à des milliers de personnes. Euh ben
quand tu as des milliers de personnes
qui parlent à des milliers de personnes,
voilà, c'est c'est aussi con que ça.
Donc ben il se trouve que les Russes ont
mis un petit peu de
de enfin de de matière grise là-dessus.
On se sont structurés, sont organisés
tout ça. Mais bien avant eux, il y a les
Chinois, il y a il y a les Coréens.
Regarde comment ça se passe en Corée
quoi. Enfin
du Sud, la la l'élection influencée par
de la structure fine énorme.
Exactement. Enfin, c'est euh le enfin
l'exemple de la Corée du Sud, pour moi,
ça a été vraiment l'un des premiers euh
vraiment symptomatique et euh et
perceptible. Enfin, un truc qui a eu un
réel effet.
Euh alors après tu peux regarder alors
le truc qui est super rigolo, c'est de
regarder la Corée du Sud avec la Corée
du Nord. La Corée du Nord en fait qui a
son qui qui a son petit réseau internet,
le Cyong en fait qui est qui est
complètement déconnecté d'internet quoi.
En fait
c'est une sorte de c'est comme à OL en
fait quand tu si tu as connu AOL avec
ton abonnement illimité ben voilà, ils
ont une sorte d'AOL en fait nord-coréen
et euh
les mecs en fait comme ils arrivent pas
à communiquer par internet, qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ? qui pose des gros
haut-parleurs en fait à la frontière et
puis diffuse à la radio en mettant les
HP à donf quoi. Bah c'est pareil en fait
c'est pas euh c'est pas nouveau. C'est
ce que dit Antoine, c'est clairement pas
nouveau quoi. C'est comme enfin tu vois
si on parle de démocratie et de trucs
comme ça et de de vilain cyber
terroriste. Quand tu parles de d'olivier
c'est parce qu'il est barbu et tout mais
il a été bien condamné. Mais euh tu
regardes ce que fait la CIA aux
États-Unis qui a bon pareil dans les
révélations Snowden, tu as ton lot de
truc sur voilà les les
hackers ou les cors de de la CIA qui
développent des outils pour aller euh
trouer toute la planète. Bon, c'est pas
nouveau quoi. Enfin, le
on fait avec Babar.
Ouais, on fait avec Babar. Nous,
nous on a Babar.
Nous, on a barbar.
Vous expliquez un peu Babar ? Oui, bah
c'était pareil quoi. C'était un une arme
pareil pour euh pour
Cocorico quand même.
Ouais, Cocorico. Ouais,
Cocoro. M in France.
Ouais, on l'a appelé Bab. Bon,
on l' appelé Bab la créativité hein.
Voilà.
Mais non, non, mais tout ça c'est pas
nouveau quoi. Les l'espionnage
économique, euh espionnage pour
l'influence, le fait de retourner des
gens, enfin tout ça. C'est c'est mieux
comme le monde.
Quand vous voyez Vladimir Poutine taper
sur Telegram,
ça vous fait penser à quoi ? Est-ce que
on a moyen de se sécuriser ? Alors,
j'enchaîne sur cette question là. On va
faire une petite transition.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
petits conseils pour sécuriser nos
communications,
échanger d'une façon un peu plus safe ?
Est-ce que vous avez confiance en tort ?
Commençons par le début. Telegram
Vladimir Poutine. Telegram. Alors moi
déjà Telégramos
[Musique]
qui ne sont pas audités, qui ne sont pas
ouverts, qui sont pas j'ai une enfin
voilà, j'ai une méfiance déjà de base.
Euh je préfère avoir affaire à des gens
qui vont faire un projet qui est
complètement open source, libre dont le
code est auditable et qui a été audité
par des tiers et tout ça.
Comme quoi ? Euh
comme quoi euh bah enfin typiquement OTR
par exemple, voilà, enfin c'est tu tu
prends un truc comme OTR qui a une
surcouche de chiffrement pour de la
messagerie instantanée, pour de l'IRC,
des choses comme ça. Bon bah ça, tu sais
que le truc est à peu près clean. Tu
sais que c'est audité, tu sais qu'il y a
une communauté derrière, tu sais que
c'est maintenu, tu sais que quand il y a
un flow en fait dans dans dans un c et
tout ça, tu sais que ça va être patché
très très rapidement. Et euh et c'est
clairement pas le cas en fait sur
Telegram parce que bah Telegram c'est
une boîte noire à chiffrement en fait.
On ne sait pas. Ils ont ils ont ils ont
développé en fait leur propre
trembouille et tout ça. Euh les mecs
proposent en fait des des bug bounti
c'est-à-dire qui proposent en fait à des
hackers de venir essayer de péter un
petit peu leur leur chiffrement et enfin
mais enfin bon c'est ça reste en fait ce
qu'on appelle du black box. Donc tu vas
auditer le truc de manière extérieure et
tu vas pas forcément voir des fautes de
programmation, des fautes
d'implémentation en fait dans la la
manière de coder des mecs. Donc c'est
incomplet.
signal
signal j'ai un petit peu plus de
sympathie pour
Silent Phone,
beaucoup plus de sympathie pour et parce
que enfin son Phone bah derrière c'est
Zimerman donc c'est le papa de PGP c'est
des mecs qui ont fait leur preuve c'est
des gars en fait qui ment en fait PGP
ils sont fait un peu maître non
ben enfin tout le monde se fait mettre à
partir d'un moment en fait où tu vas
implémenter
sont fait mettre à combien à 100 million
je sais Enfin, enfin franchement je
quand il y a un doute, il n'y a pas de
doute, non ?
Ben c'est un petit peu ça. Donc mais de
toute façon, à partir du moment où tu ne
fais confiance qu'à un seul système de
chiffrement, un seul système de de
protection tout simplement,
ben tu t'exposes en fait à la confiance
que tu octrois à ce système quoi. Donc
les gens, il faut il faut les
multiplier, quoi.
Confiance. Ta confiance en tort,
elle est relative.
Relative. Pourquoi ? Elle est relative
parce que euh
[Musique]
parce que déjà en fait on utilise des
outils. Alors tu prends le Tor Brower
par exemple, il y a eu euh les attaques
en fait de de la NSA, de la C enfin sur
qui ont fait grand bruit et tout ça,
mais c'était pas le résotant en fait qui
avait été attaqué, c'était le navigateur
via une vieille librairie JavaScript qui
avait été complètement trouée. OK,
d'accord. Les mecs, ils avaient pas
foutu à jour en fait leur Tor Browser.
Le truc où j'ai un petit peu plus de mal
en fait, c'est ce que je te disais,
c'est faire confiance en fait à un seul
système de protection de ta vie privée.
Ça devient opérant à mon sens à partir
du moment où tu les multiplies. Euh tu
peux très bien rentrer dans Thor via un
VPN qui va sauter sur un bridge et
sortir sur Thor.
Genre un VPN Bluetooth.
Il y a pas il y a plus de VPN Bluetooth.
C'est terminé ça.
Merde.
Et euh et voilà. Enfin, tu peux faire ce
genre de chos et il faut le faire. C'est
il faut multiplier en fait. C'est c'est
faire ce qu'on appelle du cascading.
C'est enfin pour moi c'est important de
le faire quoi. Tu ne peux pas faire
confiance à un seul système de
protection de ta vie privée si vraiment
tu es activiste, si ta vie est en
danger, si tes sources sont en danger et
tout ça quoi.
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
conseilles Antoine ? Non, mais pareil
mais ce que disait Olivier tout à
l'heure
est
est assez intéressant, c'est que si tu
deviens la cible en fait précise
de d'interception étatique,
un peu comme tout le monde ici quoi.
Ouais. Non, parce que enfin, ouais, je
sais pas en fait, franchement, j'en sais
rien. On saura jamais. C'est couvert par
le secret des Frances. Donc voilà. Mais
si tu deviens la cible d'une d'une
écoute par par un état quel qu'il soit,
tu ne pourras pas y échapper tout le
temps en fait. Donc euh tu peux te
ménager des petits moments de voilà en
multipliant les couches de chiffrement
et machin. Tu veux brouiller les pistes
pendant un petit moment mais ça marche
pas indéfiniment. Même les meilleurs se
font prendre quoi. Si tu prends Enfin
moi je trouve l'exemple est assez rigolo
de Lou sec. à la grande époque, ils ont
d'ffrayé la chronique pendant des mois,
ils balançaient tout ce qu'ils avaient
hacké, ils avaient un compte Twitter,
ils avaient pendant un moment un site
web et cetera. Personne arrivait à les
retrouver puis voilà, un jour il ils se
sont fait prendre quoi. C'est ça dépend
des moyens qui sont mis en face. Donc du
coup euh il y a pas de solution miracle
en fait. Quand tu es journaliste, que tu
dois mener une investigation qui rend en
contradiction avec un état, comment tu
fais pour maintenir 5 minutes de vie
privée, pour échanger avec tes sources,
pour protéger tes sources ? Est-ce que
les journalistes français
sont correctement formés pour protéger
leurs sources ? Est-ce que Wikiliak
arrive vraiment à protéger ses sources ?
Est-ce que tu as des conseils à donner à
nos à nos communautés respectives ? Bah
je t'attends sur les conseils aussi
hein.
Ouais, je sais pas si euh
la machine à écrire façon russe.
Ouais. Même la machine à écrire en fait,
elle a une signature. Donc euh c'est
compliqué. Chaque chaque touche a une
signature.
Non, ce qui euh ce qui ce qui ce qui est
le plus évident, c'est que il faut
privilégier les contacts dans la vie
réelle, dans un mid space,
dans un endroit bruyant et public, mais
euh
je pense que c'est les vieilles méthodes
qui fonctionnent le mieux, les ton
carnet d'adresse, si tu si tu as des
noms de gens que tu veux protéger, bah
tu vas les appeler autrement. Et voilà.
et les numéros de téléphone, tu vas
changer un chiffre, voilà, enfin tu
trouves des solutions pour le cas où il
y aurait une perquisition. Mais euh faut
pas perdre de vue non plus que même si
on fait du journalisme d'investigation
euh que ce soit sur reflet ou moi de
temps en temps au Canard enchaîné ou
d'autres trucs euh enfin voilà, j'ai pas
mal bossé récemment sur les dossiers
terro
terrorisme. Euh quand tu fais ça de
toute façon à la fin ton papier il va
être rendu public. Tu as des CD pour
moi,
hein.
Tu as décédé pour moi.
Non, mais tu vois quand tu euh
C'est moi qui a décédé.
Quand tu euh quand tu fais une enquête,
c'est pour qu'à un moment soit rendue
publique. Donc euh
ce que tu veux cacher, euh voilà, c'est
éventuellement des sources euh mais pas
ce que tu as raconté.
Olivier.
Alors le l'histoire de la protection des
sources, c'est toujours en fait un un
éternel débat.
J'ai été euh confronté à euh à former en
fait des gens
dans dans le dans le Moyen-Orient
qui était mais très très exposé à euh
enfin c'est là on parle pas de censure,
on parle de menace physique directe
quoi. Tu vois par exemple un collectif
de femmes journalistes palestiniennes
quoi. et tu leur explique
menacé par Sahal,
menacé très directement par T Saal et
euh et même en fait enfin chez elle par
euh enfin euh par le pouvoir palestinien
parce que c'était des femmes
journalistes. Des femmes journalistes
attention
euh dont certaines avaient perdu leur
mari enfin dans dans la guerre en fait
tout simplement quoi. Et et c'est très
compliqué en fait pour toi de te dire
bah que tu vas former ces gens-là à la
protection des souven quoi et que tu
leur dis par exemple Facebook faut
éviter quoi.
Et quand tu leur expliques ça, ben
franchement elles fond dans l'arme et
t'expliqu Facebook c'est un petit peu le
lien qu'elles ont avec le monde
extérieur quoi. Bah là tu te retrouves
comme un con leur dire ben ouais alors
il va falloir que vous continuez à
utiliser Facebook. Comment on va faire
pour le faire de manière sécure quoi ?
Bon courage.
Voilà.
Donc il y a euh enfin quand tu parles de
sécurité, de protection des sources et
tout ça en fait on parle vraiment de de
protection du contexte. On parle de de
de quel est ton propre contexte à toi,
de quel est le contexte en fait de ta
source
et comment te sécuriser toi et sécuriser
ta source
et sécuriser tes proches et sécuriser
les proches de ta source.
C'est ça. Et et ben c'est forcément
compliqué en fait. C'est pas, il y a pas
de logiciel magique, il y a pas un truc
qui va crypter tes communications et
envoyé dans les dark internet enfin
justement non mais je suis exprès. Euh
et qui va t'envoyer dans les dark les
les darknets et les machins comme ça là.
Enfin voilà,
faut faire du don technologique. Là, on
repasse à l'ancienne.
Il y a il y a des moments où oui, il y a
besoin clairement, enfin il y a
clairement un besoin. Euh après, il y a
des moments où le le la technologie
elle-même peut suffire. Tu parlais par
exemple de Wikileag tout à l'heure peut
causer de Bradley pardon Chelsea Maling
sinon je vais me faire include. Euh
c'est mais
alors Chelsea qui était en fait avant
Bradley mais qui a changé. Alors le
soldat de Chelsea Bradley Manigne, ça va
? C'est inclusif ? C'est bon ?
D'accord.
Euh ne me fais pas le vieux hackur, s'il
te plaît. Je je fais pas le vieux
hackur, enfin c'est Non, simplement
c'est lui qui sait porter préjudice à
lui-même quelque part, qui s'est qui
s'est autogrillé
ou qui s'est sacrifié pour l'intérêt
général.
Non, il n'avait pas besoin de se
sacrifier comme il l'a fait à ce
moment-là.
Clairement, il a il s'est grillé. Je
suis désolé. Il s'est grillé. Wikileak
aurait pu essayer de protéger ses
sources comme ils peuvent machin et tout
ça quoi.
Il a voulu passer pour un martyre.
Non mais à partir du moment où il a
commencé à raconter à quelqu'un que il
était derrière le le question forcément
voilà
et qui l'a raconté à
qui l'a raconté aux autorités
américaines. Il
a raconté un journaliste, comment il
s'appelle ?
Euh je me rappelle plus du nom du mec.
Enfin journaliste super connu. Enfin
Ouais ouais.
qui s'est évidemment empressé d'aller
balancer ça à la NSA ou à la C.
Il y a beaucoup, excusez-moi d'appeler
ça comme ça, mais il y a beaucoup de
balances chez les journalistes.
Ben, bizarrement chez les journalistes
américains après le 11 septembre, il y a
eu beaucoup de balance. Ouais,
effectivement. Ouais.
Non mais si tu remontes super loin dans
l'histoire, alors là il y a plus
personne qui s'en souvient peut-être à
part moi, mais tu avais une
le perf. Mais ouais, mais non mais c'est
rigolo parce que au tout début des
histoires de hackur et tout début du
web, en fait, tu avais une pseudo
journaliste américaine qui euh
euh qui voilà qui euh qui s qui a essayé
de de d'infiltrer en fait entre
guillemets le le le petit parce que
enfin ce qui s'appelait la scène en
fait, les les le monde des hackurs et
qui après euh raconter.
Euh, tu avais aussi ce journaliste,
pareil, j'ai oublié le nom,
euh qui euh qui a participé à la track
de
de Kevin Mythick. Bon, euh,
il est toujours Ouais, il est toujours
il est toujours aussi opérationnel ou
raconte autant,
il est toujours il est devenu très con
en fait. Maintenant, il vend du zéro.
Voilà,
voilà. C'est enfin voilà, c'est devenu
une [__] enfin voilà c'est devenu une
[__] de la sécurité quoi. Fair quoi
quoi.
Expliqu il faut expliquer zé euh ils
vont des vulnérabilité à des états enfin
voilà il il fait il fait du business en
fait de de vulnérabilité informatique
quoi
pour créer des armes des armes crées
numériques tout simp. Est-ce que la
communauté a, si si on peut appeler ça
comme ça, est-ce que est-ce que la
communauté du HAC a une responsabilité
dans la propagation d'armes numérique ?
Est-ce qu'il faut pas qu'on nous on se
fasse passer le message entre nous ? Ça
suffit ces conneries les
C'est un sujet. Ouais.
Alors oui, enfin moi je suis un petit
peu je suis un petit peu partagé
là-dessus parce que en fait déjà il y a
pas une communauté du ha, tu as plein de
communautés.
C'est pour ça que j'ai mis les
voilà tu tu as plein de communautés en
fait de de développeurs, des de gens qui
sont dans l'infosécurité. Tu as des gens
qui défendent, tu as des gens qui
attaquent et tout ça. Les gens qui
attaquent sont pas forcément les
méchants. Les gens qui défendent sont
pas sont pas forcément les gentils. Tu
prends un mec qui va te vendre ton des
appliance de merde en fait qui qui te
bloque du clic à de balles quoi. Mais
enfin voilà, il le vendent très très
cher
et voilà, ils font pas avancer la
sécurité non plus, surtout quand il
collent dénoncer Maning.
Pardon ?
Adrienne Lamot.
Adrienne Lama, c'est ça.
C'est un ha un hacker.
Oui, c'est un hackur et qui est
journaliste en fait aujourd'hui pour je
sais plus quel truc. Puis faut regarder
en fait, je sais qu'il bosse pour c'est
pas le journaliste, on appelle ça une
he une balance,
c'est bah ouais enfin voilà enfin bon il
est je sais qu'il a il a il a des
fonctions de journaliste.
Antoine Antoine
oui c'est un problème de de d'éthique
encore une fois quoi. C'est même pas une
question de moral en fait, c'est une
question d'éthique personnelle. Est-ce
que tu veux participer à ce genre de
choses ? J'ai écrit pas mal d'articles
au reflet sur justement ce problème
d'éthique pour les gens qui bossent sur
des trucs comme Amesis et cetera qui
vendent à Kaddafi. Voilà, tu tu
développes un produit informatique, tu
tu pisses de la ligne de code et tu te
poses pas de questions. Peut-être parce
que tu as pas je sais pas, tu as
peut-être pas les connaissances
nécessaires. Tu sais peut-être pas que
Kaddafi est un est un méchant. que tu as
totalement perdu confiance dans dans tes
concitoyens et que tu es devenu
Ouais mais attends quand tu marge à 6000
€ par mois au bout d'un moment tu en as
rien à branler quoi. Enfin
pour le minimum.
Attends je je vais être super clair.
Quand quand tu es développeur quand tu
es développeur que tu sors de l'école
qu'on te propose un job en fait à 5000 €
par mois
mais qu'est-ce que tu en as branlé de
ton éthique quoi ? tu es déjà tu sors de
l'école donc l'éthique tu sais même pas
ce que c'est quoi. Enfin voilà, on te
propose 5000 boules par mois quoi.
Qu'est-ce que tu en as branlé de
l'éthique quoi. Enfin c'est enfin c'est
aussi con que ça quoi.
L'éthique c'est autre chose.
J'en connais j'en connais qui prennent
20 plaques par mois et qui ont de
l'éthique hein.
Ouais mais c'est justement c'est c'est
pas une question de morale c'est bien
c'est c'est important les mots parce que
en fait la morale c'est un truc qui est
plus ou moins partagé par l'ensemble de
la population. En l'éthique c'est super
personnel, c'est qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire et qu'est-ce que tu veux pas faire
en fonction de tes propres convictions ?
Un message à leur faire passer.
Ouais, ne faites pas ce genre de truc.
Ouais, bien sûr. Faites autre chose.
Même si c'est même si vous gagnez moins
d'argent, mais faites quelque chose qui
fait que ben vous-même vous pouvez vous
regarder dans un miroir.
En fait, c'est non seulement le faites
pas, non se non seulement le faites pas,
mais de toute façon si vous le faites,
vous allez le reprendre dans la gueule à
un moment ou un autre, quoi. C'est aussi
con que ça quoi.
C'est c'est une évidence si tu veux.
Quand tu sais que tu as participé à un
truc et qu'il y a des gens qui ont été
torturés sur la base de ton outil, bah
éthiquement, ça pose un problème. Enfin,
peut-être qu'il y a des gens non, mais
quand même ça ça doit pas être simple.
Quand tu lis les récits des gens, tu
vois, Libé est allé les chercher, les
gens qui ont été torturés en Libye sur
la base du produit vendu par Amesis.
Donc
ils les ont fait parler, tu lis leur
témoignage, tu es pas super zen quoi.
Enfin si tu sais que tu as participé à
ça.
Question d'internet que je viens de
recevoir. Quels devraient être les axes
principaux et jusqu'à quel niveau de
détail aller dans l'éducation des jeunes
générations pour leur permettre
d'adhérer, d'appréhender l'outil
informatique dans notre société ?
Wouh
! Ça c'est une vaste question en fait.
Enfin déjà, il y a le premier truc,
c'est la base de la base, quoi. Enfin,
c'est te demander euh à quoi ça sert en
fait l'informatique. C'est de te
demander qu'est-ce qu'on peut en faire
et c'est quoi les implications de ce que
moi je vais faire. Donc la la base de la
base en fait quand tu vas coller en fait
un gosse sur internet, c'est qu'il
prenne conscience de sa propre identité
sur internet et de ce qu'il en fait.
Donc en gros, comment il va communiquer
avec d'autres personnes, ce qu'il va
laisser en fait sur internet, ce qu'il
va écrire et ce qui va constituer plus
tard sa carte d'identité numérique
quelque part. Donc la la première la
première des choses à faire, c'est lui
apprendre en fait à gérer sa propre
identité numérique.
Antoine,
c'est super compliqué en fait parce que
effectivement ce que dit Olivier, c'est
c'est tout à fait vrai. on a ce qu'on a
enfin ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
espèce de projection numérique de
nous-même sur le réseau et qui est
forcément incomplète et qui peut selon
ce que les gens recherchent sur nous euh
être à la fois partiel et partial. En
gros, de la même façon que quand tu vas
dans un dîner, tu rencontres quelqu'un
que tu as jamais vu, s'il a eu une
mauvaise journée, euh tu vas peut-être
penser que c'est un gros con parce que
voilà, il est pas sympa et tout ce que
tu veux.
Voilà, il est pas souriant. Bon, te dire
bon, celui-là est pas terrible, quoi.
Mais si tu l'avais rencontré un jour où
il avait eu une bonne journée, peut-être
que tu te serais dit la chose
complètement inverse et ça tiens, c'est
un mec sympa. Bon voilà, tuen sais rien.
C'est parce que c'est un petit moment un
morceau de sa personnalité. C'est pareil
sur internet. ce qu'on laisse, c'est un
morceau de notre personnalité et ça peut
prêter à confusion et les gens peuvent
tirer des conclusions qui sont fausses
sur nous-mêmes. Donc c'est effectivement
un problème toute cette toutes ces
générations qui arrivent aujourd'hui et
qui euh un ne comprennent pas comment ça
marche, de ne voi pas du tout la portée
de ce qu'il balance sur internet.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est de enfin oui,
il faut bien le dire quoi. Internet
c'est devenu un peu le bar des copains.
Ouais. où tu as Polo qui est tout bourré
qui sort tr conneries quoi.
Mais non mais voilà, il polo au bar des
amis, il est un peu bourré au comptoir,
il balance une connerie, tout le monde
s'en fout mais au bout d'un moment il
vient un peu chiant et voilà. Ben c'est
un peu ça maintenant les réseaux sociaux
les gamins, ils parlent sans sans frein
en fait et en fait en parlant sans
frein, il laisse une trace qui va donner
une image d'eux qui plus tard peut-être
leur posera problème au moment où ils
rechercheront un boulot ou un truc comme
ça. Mais éduquer les enfants à ça, c'est
super compliqué. Pourquoi ? Parce que un
gamin, il a pas du tout conscience de
ces trucs là. Que ça c'est que les
parents même sont pas éduqués. Enfin, il
faut te rendre compte d'un truc, c'est
que aujourd'hui, tu as euh 8 gamins sur
10 qui à un mois se retrouve avec leurs
photos sur Facebook.
Ouais,
c'est enfin enfin c'est complètement
délirant quoi.
Une petite question internet qui vient
de tomber. Comment savoir si on est si
on est surveillé ? Pour l'interrogation,
doit-on utiliser un paquet analyzer
comme Wire Shark ?
Alors euh ouais, TCP Dump ou Wor Shark,
enfin voilà. Euh enfin TCP nom c'est
quand même plus classe. Enfin voilà
c'est enfin c'est la même base que Wers
Shark mais bon Shark c'est un peu plus
graphique et tout ça quoi.
Ça pas beaucoup aidé
euh mais enfin bon si tu as un Arduino
qui tourne tu vas pas faire tourner W
Shark, tu mettras tes CP d'homme, ça
marche mieux. Euh c'est euh
alors tu ne verras il y a plusieurs
types de surveillance. Donc soit tu te
fais trop janer machin et tout ça.
Alors trop jané ça veut dire
tu te manges en fait un cheval de 3. En
gros tu vas avoir un kiloger. Donc avant
que même que tu aille sur tor et que tu
tapes ta commande en fait de 800 g de
cocaïne sur un black market. 800 g.
Voilà. Conso personnel
pour la semaine.
Conso personnel, tu vas taper en fait un
truc, ben tu vas dire "Ouais, c'est
sécur en fait, je suis s le darknet."
Mais non, en fait parce que le kyoger,
le truc qui va intercepter les frappes
en fait sur ton clavier va le faire
avant que ça soit chiffré. Donc il va y
avoir un canal de retour et le mec en
fait qui t'a inoculé en cheval de 3 va
pouvoir en fait regarder ce que tu
pire que ça. Il y a même pire que ça. Si
ça ça c'est l'exemple de base en fait.
Il a pire. Pierre contre vas-y si tu
veux on peut parler de temps de PS et de
ces trucs là mais c'est vieux, c'est des
modé, c'est des trucs des années 80 ça
déjà.
Ouais, c'est notre âge
mais voilà.
Non non mais c'est trop vieux. Euh
alors simplement pour te dire que enfin
tu peux pas à partir du moment où tu vas
tomber enfin sur un truc sur une
interception
qui va fonctionner en fait sur du 10
packets inspection
via ton FAI ou un truc comme ça, tu ne
peux pas le savoir. Pourquoi ? parce que
c'est des équipements qui sont passifs.
Donc même si tu t'amuses à scanner en
fait tout internet, tu sauras pas qu'il
y a tel équipement qui est en train de
d'intercepter tes communications parce
que l'équipement est passif. C'est veut
dire que si tu le pinges, il te répond
pas. déjà
il est au cul de ta ligne, il il
intercepte les paquets, il renvoie les
paquets, on peut te modifier tes petits
paquets enfin et te changer des
informations et t'injecter de la pub et
tout ça comme le fait SFR en fait sur du
mobile et des conneries comme ça parce
que c'est les mêmes technologies hein.
C'était SFR en fait à l'époque.
Euh
mais Orange enfin l'a probablement fait
enfin oui Orange non Orange Préférence
en fait c'était enfin c'est un optimine
he quand même.
S te proposa que dal il t'optimisa tes
pages, il te niquait tes images, il te
niqua tout enfin voilà et puis il
t'injectait de la pub. OK super donc tu
me changes mes pages web et moi je me
suis retrouvé à me rendre compte mais
par un truc complètement débile, c'est
que j'avais plus de connexion à la
maison. J'avais un abonnement SFR. Donc
je me connecte en fait en tetering 4G en
fait pour faire un pen test quoi. Je
commence à peine tester un truc puis je
me rends compte que c'est pas les bons
serveurs quoi. C'est j'étais en train
d'attaquer SFR quoi en fait quoi.
Euh bah j'étais pas content. C'est enfin
clairement j'étais pas content quoi.
Enfin c'est déjà d'une part tu me
changes mes pages web.
D'autre part en fait l'internet que tu
me donnes et pas celui que je demande.
Enfin ce que je veux c'est internet
c'est pas ton intranet. Euh ouais enfin
j'étais pas content. Enfin, c'est euh
c'est sûr que tu peux pas euh tu tu
c'est c'est très très compliqué de
d'échapper à ça et de te rendre compte
euh que tu es clairement tu ne peux pas
voir enfin tu ne peux pas voir qu'il y a
un équipement passif en fait qui qui
t'écoute. C'est
donc papier crayon les gars. Autre
question d'internet. Dans quelle mesure
la France est-elle armée dans cette
cyberguerre cybernétique ou cyber
cyberguerre cybernétique de surveillance
?
Une cyberguerre cybernétique ?
Ouais. Ouais. Mais la question est
formulée façon alors ça ça fait des
cyber cyberm.
Ouais, ça fait des cybermorts.
Dans quelle mesure la France est-elle
armée pour cette cybergaerre
de surveillance ?
Alors, il y a pas de cybergerre de
surveillance, il y a toujours eu de la
et dans quelle proportion cette
puissance est-elle utilisée contre les
citoyens français ?
Waouh ! Alors, il y a deux questions.
Euh, il y a pas de cybergarde de
surveillance. Il y a toujours eu en fait
des guerres économiques, il y a toujours
eu de trucs enfin il y a toujours eu des
guerres en fait quelque part
direct ou indirect et tout ça et dans
les gars indirects il se trouve que
internet c'est un truc qui est vachement
bien parce que tu peux essayer de pas te
faire goler. Donc essayer de pas te
faire goler, ça veut dire qu'en fait le
concept d'attribution quand tu fais une
connerie forcément un hackur chinois.
C'est forcément les Russes. C'est
toujours comme ça.
C'est BL Bruchia.
Voilà c'est c'est soit les Russes soit
les Chinois. Enfin voilà c'est normal.
comme ça c'est à pendant un moment.
Ah oui oui les Coréens du Nord ça c'est
bien les
Corennet
voilà c'est les mecs qui ont pas
d'internet en fait qui sont obligés
d'aller faire du tapin en fait sur un
satellite chinois quoi. Mais enfin c'est
c'est coréen, il y a pas de problème.
Euh
donc comment te dire ? Ouais. Alors, il
y a une cybergerre qui fait des
cybermorts avec plein de cyber bidules
autour. Mais en fait, on en a rien à
[__] parce que c'est pas ça le
problème. Il y a toujours une guerre
économique. Internet est juste un moyen
supplémentaire pour appuyer en fait
quelque part ton arsenal et enfin c'est
c'est une partie de ton arsenal. Non
mais pour pour revenir à la question, on
n'est pas complètement mauvais hein. On
babare non mais on a quand même inventé
le DPI en France dans une université
française Pier Marcury Olipsis c'est pas
complètement neutre. On est aussi des
très gros poseurs de câbles sous-marins.
Donc ces câbles là on a un peu la main
dessus
en fait
parce que ouais c'est b le pauvre. Et
d'ailleurs tiens, il y a un type qui
vient de refaire exactement le même le
même record 105 m. On va
se faire taper sur la tête parce qu'on
se fait des PR
po
arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez.
105 m
105 m à poil merde.
Donc donc la géopolitique des câbles,
c'est très intéressant ce que vous
posez.
Comment ça se fait que toute l'Afrique
est reliée à Brest ?
À Brest ? C'est quoi Brest ? Tu tous les
tous les câbles de d'aff
parce que tu as eu un jus d'orange ce
matin, c'est pour ça.
Ouais, ça doit être ça. Alors en fait, a
il y a pas que Brest en fait, il y a euh
a il y a Marseille, il y a Toulon, il y
a enfin voilà, il y a ce qu'on appelle
les landing points en fait de de fibres
sous-marines. Donc en fait un réseau de
câbles sous-marins de fibre optique
sous-marine pour
faire transiter du trafic d'opérateur à
opérateur et simplement en fait que de
connecter les pays en fait au réseau
internet.
Euh faut savoir que ces données sont
publiques. Il y a des cartes
tout à fait publiques de de l'état en
fait du réseau de câble en fait
sous-marin et tout ça. Donc on peut
regarder à peu près comment ça
fonctionne. Et c'est le premier truc en
fait qu'on avait fait à l'époque de la
révolution tunisienne et tout ça. On
s'est dit ben voilà comment ça se passe
internet en Tunisie. OK, il y a un seul
lending point enfin voilà qui a qui
arrive à la TI. Donc l'agence tunisienne
internet à l'époque, enfin voilà.
Et euh et ben il y a une salle blanche
en fait dans lequelle il y a du bull, il
y a du
en gros il y avait du amésis quoi. Et
euh
et ouais, tu as un gros tuyau, enfin un
point de concentration dans lequel bah
c'est ultra facile du coup en fait de
d'écouter enfin le trafic de tout le
pays. Et
c'est marrant parce que il y a eu un
article sur reflet qui était assez
intéressant à l'époque qui est un peu
passé inaperçu. C'est une des premières
slides en fait qui qui ont été publié
dans les histoires Snowden. C'est en
fait un
une slide moche comme toutes les autres
où tu as les tuyaux qui relient les
États-Unis au reste du monde.
Moi je l'ai trouvé très très belle cette
slide.
Ouais. Et tu te rends compte en fait que
leur connectivité avec l'Afrique est
très très faible. En revanche, la nôtre
est très très forte. Et donc c'est
à la lumière de ce détail technique, tu
comprends mieux pourquoi aujourd'hui la
France est devenue membre des de du
groupe des Five Eyes, c'est-à-dire en
fait les les
un partenaire privilégié
un partenaire privilégié du monde de
renseignement américain. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'on peut leur fournir énormément
de données interceptées en Afrique, donc
sur les terrains dit de terrorisme. Donc
on est devenu des gens intéressants. On
parle de l'Afrique mais si quand tu
regardes un petit peu en fait le la
géographie des câbles,
euh on distribue par exemple en fait
toute l'Afrique du Nord mais on arrive
mais très très loin dans le Moyen-Orient
quoi. Et le Moyen-Orient, je vais pas te
faire un dessin. Enfin voilà, quand tu
es américain, enfin voilà, quand tu es
américain et que en gros
tu vas faire du renseignement dans le
Moyen-Orient, tu es un peu grillé quoi.
Enfin, c'est euh en France, c'est un peu
plus voilà, c'est un peu plus cool quoi.
Tu vois, francophone, on est cool.
Tiens, regarde, on vous aide. Alors, les
Nordiques aussi sont super forts
là-dessus. Les Suédois, les Danois,
enfin sont très très forts. Enfin, sur
le Moyen-Orient du moins. Mais les
riquins sont grillés là-bas, quoi. Ils
sont totalement grillés là-bas. Et donc
ils ont un intérêt certain à travailler
avec
l'Europe, à travailler notamment avec la
France qui a qui a déployé un réseau de
câble champ et tout ça. Il y a il y a
des programmes en fait d'échange
d'information, faut bien comprendre un
truc, c'est que le renseignement c'est
une place de marché tout simplement.
C'est si je te donne ça, il faut que tu
me donnes ça et enfin voilà, il y a rien
qui est gratuit tout simplement.
Est-ce que tu es plutôt par Cali Linux ?
Ouais ouais c'est pour c'est c'est Linux
amélioré c'estd c'est plus
non alors moi je peux expliquer pourquoi
enfin tout simplement enfin c'est il y a
un truc qui est tout con c'est que
alors Cali déjà c'est du full root de
base. Alors après tu peux le tuner enfin
voilà il y a pas de problème et tout
quoi mais c'est du full root ça pue mais
non mais si je suis désolé tu peux pas
utiliser ça au quotidienfin tu étais es
à poil quoi. C'est tu te fais pa tu te
fais défoncer la gueule quoi. Parotte il
y a un petit peu il y a un effort. Voilà
ils ont fait un truc quoi. Alors ça se
télécharge où ? Parotte,
c'est euh c'est Parot Project, je sais
même plus. Enfin parf tu tapes Parot
Security ou Parot Project, je sais plus.
Enfin c'est euh
Antoine, tu l'as testé ? Oua j'ai
regardé mais bon moi je suis pas euh
aussi fin technicien qu'Olivier donc il
y a plein de trucs qui m'échappent. Mais
moi que j'ai plus le droit d'utiliser
normalement donc je
parce que tu as été condamné d'ailleurs.
Ouais ben oui c'est normal. Donc ce ce
cyberroriste ça te crée des problèmes
d'avoir des périod parce que j'ai pas eu
l'arrêt enfin je sais que j'ai été
condamné mais j'ai pas encore eu
l'arrêt. Euh si j'étais condamné pour
détention de mes outils de travail, oui
effectivement ça va poser problème.
Enfin ça va poser problème jusqu'au
moment où enfin on va dépoyer un un truc
sur une VM à l'étranger hein. C'est pas
le problème.
Tu veux que je les stock chez toi chez
moi ?
Mais ouais mais c'est vrai que tu as des
trucs en Russie toi.
Ouais pourquoi pas.
Pas que pas que. Pas que
D'accord. OK mais oui ouais pas de
problème. Mais non ça va devenir
effectivement peut-être je sais pas j'ai
pas l'arrêt en fait je sais que j'ai été
condamné pourquoi. Enfin je mais je sais
que j'étais condamné.
C'était pour calmer les haqueurs qu'on
t'a massacré.
C'était pardon
c'est c'était pour te calmer qu'on t'a
massacré qu'on t'a poursuivi qu'on s'est
acharné.
C'est raté
et c'était pour calmer d'autres hackurs
de de
Je pense que c'est raté aussi.
Non clairement. Enfin je pense que c'est
con. Enfin non, je pense que c'était
simplement pour satisfaire
l'ego personnel d'une personne qui avait
envie de faire sa petite sa petite
jurisprudence pour briller en société.
Voilà. Et ça fait deux fois et il se
trouve que c'est la même personne.
J'ai envie de te dire que je m'en tape
le cul par terre quoi. Et euh
tu veux tu veux qu'on appelle des
copains ?
Ben non, enfin je non, j'ai même pas
besoin de passer un coup de fil à un ami
là si tu veux. Enfin c'est non. Enfin
clairement je m'en branque. Enfin c'est
Antoine c'est pas ce qui m'empêcher de
dormir.
Antoine.
Ouais. Non je crois que c'est surtout
euh c'est c'est un mauvais message
envoyé à tout le monde quoi. Enfin ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure quoi. C'est
effectivement c'est un truc des go
persos et voilà des gens qui aiment qui
aiment briller dans certains cercles
quoi.
On arrive à peu près à à la fin de notre
interview. Est-ce que vous avez un sujet
que vous voulez aborder avec nous, avec
notre communauté, avec la communauté ?
Il y a un truc qui vous passe par la
tête comme ça là ? Parce que ça vous
nous avez fait bien chier pour vous
verrouiller tous les deux et d'ailleurs
il y en a un d'ailleurs. On passe le
bonjour à Draffer. Du moins moi je
l'embrasse et à Jeff je les embrasse
parce que il nous manque aujourd'hui et
on aura l'occasion de se revoir une
prochaine fois peut-être. Vous voulez
qu'on aborde un sujet tous ensemble ?
Allez, c'est open bar là, faites-vous
plaisir. Là, il y a 100000 person de
paddle foil, mais en fait tout le monde
s'en branle en fait.
Fais-toi plaisir, on s'en fout, on est
entre nous là. Non, non, non, non. Tout
le monde vous aime. Faites-vous plaisir.
Antoine, tu as un truc que tu veux
aborder ?
Non, pas en particulier, sauf si les
gens ont des questions particulières. Je
sais pas.
Alors, faites faites péter vos questions
sur l'IRC.
Euh, je vais vous donner pendant qu'ils
sont en train de faire chauffer les
neurones, préparer un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Ah, c'est vrai, tu l' fait souvent
celle-là toi. Elle est obligatoire.
C'est c'est notre notre moelle épinière.
C'est un truc qui nous est très cher,
c'est-à-dire au moins laisser une
bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations parce que nous on est on est
vieux. Tu as eu ta tête mec.
Al moi j'en ai une qui vraiment Attends
attends attendsendsendsends attends
réfléchis.
Euh euh vous allez vous allez pas la
nuit du cette année ? Non non. Passage
en scène demain.
Alors passage en scène demain. Oui.
Petit coup de pub, faites-vous plaisir.
Euh la NDH j'aimerais énormément. Je
sais pas si je vais avoir le temps.
Enfin, c'est le problème tous les ans,
c'est que ça tombe à chaque fois en même
temps que le passage en scène. Alors, on
fait pas exprès.
Clairement, on fait pas exprès et enfin
clairement ça nous saoule. Enfin, un
passage en scène, ça nous saoule parce
que enfin moi j'ai envie aussi d'aller à
l'hôpel, tu peux pas appeler.
C'est un peu compliqué si tu veux parce
qu'on ne
on avait pas en fait de la main en fait
sur les dates qu'on avait sur les salles
qu'on obtient en comp. Non, faut
comprendre un truc, c'est que passage en
scène n'est pas un truc qui est qui est
financé et pas un truc payant. C'est un
truc qui est totalement gratuit et tout.
Il y a une association qui est derrière.
Voilà, il y a des conférences, c'est
c'est que du bénévole en fait derrière.
Cette année, il y a une grosse
organisation en plus de bénévoles. Les
mecs se sont déchirés quoi. Voilà. Trou
trouve qu' a choisi en fait cette année
euh enfin ça fait ça fait 3 4 ans
maintenant que ça a choisi
et euh et voilà. Enfin, c'est on a
malheureusement pas le choix en fait sur
les dates et tout ça. Euh mais c'est
réellement problématique parce que oui,
effectivement, nous on aimerait bien
faire la TEF aussi avec la NDH hein.
Enfin, c'est euh c'est aussi con que ça
quoi. On a quelques potes en commun
là-bas. Enfin, c'est voilà.
Antoine,
tu vas à la NDH ?
Non.
Passage en scène ?
Merde, tu fais quoi cette année ?
Il boude.
Tu boudes ?
Ouais, je boude. Ouais. Bon, vieux,
on va te véhiculer maintenant avec ta ta
petite chaise roulante.
Euh, un petit conseil pour les jeunes
générations, les gars.
Alors, conseil pour les jeunes
générations,
bah le truc de base en fait, ouais, ça
ser ça, j'ai envie de vous dire de
revenir un petit peu aux sources, de
comprendre en fait de quoi vous causez
quand vous appréhendez un petit peu le
le concept de sécurité informatique,
enfin d'informatique en règle générale,
euh c'est pas l'informatique qui est
importante, c'est internet, c'est le
réseau. Donc comprendre le réseau, ça
veut dire revenir un petit peu aux
sources, comprendre en fait pourquoi le
réseau s'est construit, comment il s'est
construit, l'importance du logiciel
libre,
comprendre que le sans le logiciel
libre, il y aurait pas d'internet et
essayer de de perpétrer un petit peu
cette de perpétuer pardon euh un petit
peu cette cette enfin c'est même pas une
tradition, c'est une obligation quoi.
Enfin, le logiciel libre est une
obligation pour internet et c'est très
important qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
jeunes qui s'impliquent dans des projets
libres pour continuer à faire vivre
internet tout simplement quoi.
Antoine,
ben moi je leur dirais de d'essayer de
de comprendre en fait que
enfin voilà le le c'est c'est le conseil
à la con, c'est euh fermez votre compte
Facebook quoi. Mais derrière, il y a le
fait de comprendre que tu as pas besoin
enfin internet à la base te fournit tous
les outils pour faire la même chose que
ce que tu fais sur Facebook, sauf que tu
vas pas filer toutes tes infos perso
à Facebook
à marque.
Donc donc voilà, donc tu peux faire
autrement et et le réseau, il a été
construit pour ça. tu peux euh
correspondre avec les gens par mail,
discuter sur l'IRC, euh poster des trucs
en faisant toi-même une contribution au
réseau, pas à Facebook. C'est quand tu
mets du contenu sur internet, tu
participes à sa croissance. Quand tu
mets du contenu sur un réseau fermé et
centralisé qui s'appelle Facebook, bah
tu contribues à rien en fait.
Olivier, tu voulais Ouais. Si un dernier
truc en fait, enfin c'est lâcher votre
téléphone quoi. Payez-vous un clavier et
lâchez votre téléphone quoi. Enfin
clairement internet c'est pas via le
téléphone. Internet mobile c'est pas le
vrai internet.
Prenez du temps derrière un écran avec
un vrai clavier. Essayez d'apprendre à
écrire ça va cava. Enfin voilà, enfin
truc de base quoi.
Antoine une question ring pour toi.
Est-ce que tu est-ce que tu comptes
faire un autre roman que il rot ? Hm. Je
m'étais posé la question pendant un
moment de refaire un truc euh au goût du
jour puisque en fait ça s'est sorti en
de mémoire euh ça devait être l'an 2000
euh 198 je crois.
Ouais, je sais pas. Ouais 98 2000 je
sais plus. Euh donc euh c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui ce serait euh ce serait
différent. La thématique pourrait être
la même mais ça serait ce serait
différent. Euh franchement euh j'ai j'ai
pas euh j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas le temps
pour le faire.
Alors euh je vais reprendre le micro
pour le mot de la fin. Euh déjà
abonnez-vous à Reflet, c'est de de
salubrité publique. Euh c'est important.
Euh euh on va refaire des émissions
autour du HAC. comment vous sécuriser,
comment protéger vos informations
personnelles, votre vie privée
et en vous donnant plein de petites tu
autour de ça, on va faire venir nos
potes un peu plus parce que ça a été
vraiment réclamé
qu'on fasse venir nos potes.
On vous remercie pour cette petite heure
et demi peut-être de d'interview et
c'était très sympa et on vous attend
pour une prochaine parce que ça vous
allait être réclamé et puis on s'arrête
là et on coupe. Merci les gars.
Merci.
[Musique]